the following is a conversation with
brian armstrong co-founder and ceo of
coinbase the largest cryptocurrency
exchange platform with 98 million users
in 100 countries listing bitcoin
ethereum cardano and over 100 popular
cryptocurrencies
i recorded this conversation with brian
before this week's sec probe into
whether some of the crypto listings are
securities and thus need to be regulated
as such
as always with conversations that
involve cryptocurrency i try to make it
timeless so that the price soaring high
or crashing down low doesn't distract
from the fundamental
technological economic social and
philosophical ideas underlying this new
form of money energy and information
our world runs on money
the exchange and store of value
and cryptocurrency seeks to build the
next chapter of how money works and what
it can do
coinbase and brian are trying to do this
by working together with regulators and
governments which is a long and
difficult road
bureaucracies resist change for better
and for worse
the latest sec probe is a good
representation of this
it is a serious attempt to limit fraud
but one that also runs the risk of
limiting innovation
and limiting financial freedom of
individuals
this is a complicated mess and i applaud
everyone involved for trying to work
through it
i hope in the end the interest of the
individual wins
decentralization after all is a hedge
against the corrupting nature of
centralized power
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's brian
armstrong
let's start with the fact that you're a
programmer what was the first program
you've ever written or the first one
that you remember
the first memory i have of programming
was probably in middle school and i
remember it was recess
and they had this like this time period
where you could read books and the other
kids were like reading comic books and
stuff and for some reason i had gotten
into decide yet i wanted to get into
computers and i was playing with
computers at home
and so i got this book i think from the
library it was called like how to learn
java in 30 days
so i was
i was reading this book at like you know
the recess
and i didn't understand anything and i
remember i went home and i tried to get
this
thing working and you know if you've
ever written a java program the first
lines are like public static void main
string args or whatever and it's just
like it's so foreign and it's so
difficult to get started and so i was
kind of frustrated i was like i don't
understand anything that's happening in
this book so the first the first thing i
wrote was probably just like a hello
world app in java
but it was so i felt like i was so
confused about what was actually
happening that i later
learned a bit of php and php was like
more fun for me because it was like oh
just print out what you want you know it
didn't have all this complexity around
it so then i got more into php i started
building like some simple websites i
think
learned some html so i think that was my
introduction to programming at least the
very beginning part yeah
you know java has a lot of uh
out of all the hello worlds you can
possibly write java is the one where i
think it's the longest yeah it's just
which is quite interesting because java
is often at least for a long time was
used as the primary programming language
to teach people how to program or at
least about object-oriented programming
i think most universities have now
switched in high school switched to
python
i'm not sure if that's the case probably
better it's easier to learn it lowers
the it makes it less scary there's like
less of a hurdle and certainly none of
them use php i love php and i feel like
it's a dirty secret i have to keep
private to myself like it's somebody i'm
seeing on the side or something like
that because uh it's just not a
respected programming language because i
think there's so many ways you can write
poor code with php yeah which is why
it's not respected yeah it's a scripting
language more so although of course
facebook built like a huge stack on top
of it and valuable company but
i still love ruby to this day ruby is
probably my favorite language python is
great too but i just love
the idea behind ruby that it's like
let's make it easier for the human
harder for the computer and make it a
joy to be expressive and all these
things so
i was never the best computer scientist
but i was a good i was good hacker i
could rapidly prototype products and
using languages like ruby do a lot of
computer science programs still use like
lisp and scheme and things like that no
no they do for that's like that's if
you're hardcore if you're legit you're
gonna do some of the functional
languages yeah i think there's a there's
a few others that popped up but
lisp is a distant memory for a lot of
people that's like somebody has to like
you go to library
you dust off the book yeah but uh scheme
a little bit i think if you're starting
i mean there's courses about languages
themselves like programming languages
yeah this might be one of those you know
how there's languages that nobody uses
anymore like ancient languages yeah
you might have to go to school in that
same way for programming languages yeah
back in the day we used to use
parentheses i of course still use emacs
as the editor for most things that i do
and emacs is is um you know a lot of the
customization you can do is in lisp
and that's the language probably when i
first
really fell in love with programming is
lisp because for
a long time throughout the earlier
history of artificial intelligence list
was the primary language but
it still had a life
in the 90s and the arts where some
people would use it
such a beautiful functional language
but it just somehow didn't pick up
um
that said i should say sort of push back
php i feel like
it's still true that most of the
web runs on php most of the back end is
still is still php
so if you look at
you know it's like the stuff that people
don't talk about it's like what what
runs most systems in the world what runs
the most
uh back end what runs most front end
yeah javascript
you know html script i think the stack
exchange surveys show javascript's most
popular language in the world i think
right oh yeah in terms of programmers
and numbers of i wonder
by survey of number of programmers on
stack
stack overflow yeah but that's also the
cutting edge right those are the people
that are just like excitedly writing
code i wonder if there's
there's people that are just like
maintaining gigantic code bases yeah
i feel like the amount of java out there
just running industrial systems has got
to be enormous and then of course in the
banking industry
finance it's like
even older stuff cobalt and whatnot but
i've been actually looking for somebody
uh to interview
who who represents uh cobalt
unfortunately like who's the figure
still
still there that holds the flag i did
you know with java founder of java
creator of java creator python creator
of c plus plus but nobody wants to hold
the flag for cobalt unfortunately even
though some of the most important
systems in the world still run on those
yeah uh like power systems and
infrastructure systems which is
fascinating which and atms and stuff
like that like a lot of stuff
that we rely on that just works and the
reason we don't change it because it
works well yeah it's written in
languages that people don't use anymore
yeah
that'd be a cool series of interviews
get get the stuff that's like tech that
was invented
40 50 years ago but still is being used
widely i mean emacs is an example of
that let me ask the big question of uh
what are cryptocurrency exchanges and
what's coinbase how does it work before
i'll ask even bigger questions but it's
just a nice kind of
pilot cleansing question of what is
coinbase
coinbase is a cryptocurrency exchange
brokerage custodian basically
we're the primary financial account for
people in the crypto economy
how they buy crypto how they store it
how they use it increasingly in
different ways we can talk about that
um so yeah we want to be the way that a
billion people hopefully access the open
financial system globally how does it
work
what uh
what's cryptocurrency
you know there's uh there's bitcoin
there's ethereum
um what does it mean to be an exchange
what does it mean to store what does it
mean to transact how does it what does
coinbase actually do
okay so you know basically in any given
market there's some people want to buy
some people who want to sell
and there's you keep an order book of
all those prices
and then um
you know if someone's willing to buy for
more than the lowest price someone's
willing to sell then you know you get a
trade to execute that's kind of how an
exchange works underneath and a
brokerage is kind of simpler than that
even you don't have to know look at the
whole order book and everything but you
just go in there and you say i want to
buy 100 of bitcoin or whatever
cryptocurrency you get a quote and if
you like it you can hit accept and you
know
the core things that we do to make all
that kind of just work make it seamless
it sounds simple on the surface
is we gotta we have to do payment
integrations you know in a variety of
places around the world to make it easy
for people to get fiat currency into
this ecosystem
we have to work on cyber security a lot
there's lots of hackers out there trying
to break into our systems and steal
crypto or to put stolen credit cards and
bank accounts and things like that into
these systems
um we have to integrate with the
blockchains themselves right which are
periodically getting updated and
having various airdrops and all kinds of
things so we're integrated with lots of
different blockchains and then we have
to store the crypto that people buy
securely as well so crypto is kind of
like storing
you store the private keys essentially
and we've invented a lot of cool
technology about how to do that securely
that helps me sleep at night
as one of the largest crypto custodians
out there
so those are some of the pieces that had
to come together to get that early
simple buy sell experience to work
and
yeah i mean coinbase actually has a lot
of different products now so we have
like an institutional product uh we we
have coinbase commerce which is like
merchant payments like stripe for crypto
we've got a self-custodial wallet which
we can talk about there's all kinds of
cool applications people are building
with web3 and they can access it through
that we just just launched an nft
product
um i've gone down the list we have we so
we're sort of like a portfolio of crypto
products now we're big enough where we
can do multiple things but yeah the core
thing we got started with and still the
majority of our revenue today is people
just want to come in and buy and sell
some crypto and we help them do that
make it simple and easy to use uh and
i'll ask you about wallet nft is about
what is it called the stripe type
coinbase commerce coinbase commerce yeah
i'll ask about all that but uh order
books and exchange what's the difference
between
that and stocks for example which
there's also order books yes i mean
stocks trade through order books too uh
sort of commodities it's all similar
type of situation so when i want to buy
one bitcoin and i see coinbase say the
price of that bitcoin
is say forty thousand dollars
and i
press buy what happens
um yeah okay so you've gotten a lot
like
you know when you press the button on
your keyboard like the electrical signal
goes up the wire on your keyboard
well that's also important the timing
right because it's not pricing
yeah it's true it's giving you a quote
right that's that's um you know some
there's a whole concept of like slippage
and like by the time the quote is
executed
um if the price has moved too much like
we may reject it and you know there's
there's various things like that but how
do i i mean what's the simple version i
can give you so we you know we'll we'll
basically check the order book give you
a quote
it's good for some period of time or for
some amount of slippage and then
what's happening is we're initiating a
debit to your payment method whether
that's a credit card or a bank account
or
you know you're storing dollars or euros
or something on our platform there's
various payment methods so we're
basically debiting that and then we're
crediting you the crypto and uh we're
taking a fee for it too so um
that's fundamentally what's happening
underneath and then there's some
interesting slippage how do you how do
you calculate the uh how much slippage
is allowed like how do you how do you
know these things
you know because order books are
fascinating
you know the dynamics of that is pretty
interesting yeah and the little i know
about it yeah so
there's a lot of people like traders who
get super into this and like high
frequency traders and arbitrage and all
kinds of interesting topics flash boys
was like an interesting book on this
whole thing you want like access to
information the fastest sometimes even
putting your
you know your thing in the data center
right next to the thing we don't allow
that colo stuff because we want it to be
more democratized
but you know basically you give a let's
say we wanted to just keep it math
simple we want to charge a one percent
fee so if you're buying a hundred
dollars of bitcoin and we'll charge you
101
you know we've presented you the amount
of bitcoin you're going to get for 100
now let's say 10 seconds later you hit
accept we go to we go to fill the order
so it's going to be
some error bound around that one percent
fee right and if we think we're actually
losing money on the trade i think we'll
often reject it so some part of the fee
the slippage is incorporated into that
averaged over
a large number of people they just just
it's fascinating because like even just
like that little detail probably
requires a lot of experimentation yeah
and it's kind of like a giant bug bounty
out there because if you get it wrong
there's people who are going to
arbitrage that and we've we've had
people sort of pen test our systems in
you know really creative ways where like
um
they'll just fire like programmatically
with apis they'll fire off like a
million different quotes and look for
one of them that's out of bounds and
then actually take that money right
there and you know we get people doing
all kinds of crazy stuff but so how do
you protect against that how do you
protect so we'll talk about cyber
security in interesting ways but there's
a lot of clever people
trying to do clever things to earn
not even just to break into the system
but to earn an edge of some kind yeah in
the system
how do you uh how do you stay one step
ahead there's no silver bullet there's a
bunch of lead bullets right so it's it's
like
you know one thing we do is we just have
good test suites right so you're testing
every piece of code that goes out that's
like just common good best practice but
it's particularly important in financial
services
another thing we do is we hire
third-party firms to try to audit this
stuff and break in another one we do is
we have a bug bounty program
so
we
basically pay white hat hackers to find
this stuff before the black hats do and
we've paid out lots of good bug bounties
so
you know
try all the above and occasionally you
don't get it right you lose some money
and then you fix it and you keep going
so
yeah let's talk about sebastian security
a little bit more yeah you mentioned
using stolen bank accounts
yeah so that's another one that's
another interesting one how do you
protect against that
okay so fraud prevention
yeah is a big topic so one of the
there's a lot of things people do but
one of the things they do is that
you use machine learning right so you
look at
protector to attack to protect against
it so
um what you want to do is kind of build
up a labeled data set of
all the different people who have turned
out to be fraudulent and good good
actors and hopefully collect as much
data as you can and then you'll you know
you might feed hundreds or thousands of
these factors into your machine learning
model it'll come back with a risk score
so you know an example of like the kinds
of factors people create or put in there
you know obviously i don't want to
disclose too many of them because it's
it's it's a cat and mouse game but just
kind of i don't know relatively well
known stuff might be
um
you know you have device fingerprints
right so like what kind of device are
you on and what fonts do you have
installed a lot of people who are
farming lots of these accounts they're
using emulators and like virtual
machines and stuff they're not like you
know an average person on that device
um and then you'll see sometimes like
one of my favorite metrics we tracked
for for this was called like improbable
travel velocity so we would we're
tracking people's ips right and you
might see someone um
who was one day in austin texas and then
like an hour later they were in london
or something it's like well that's very
improbable i mean sometimes people are
using vpns so you got to be careful with
that because like there's legitimate
people who use vpns too but
if it's not possible for them to have
gotten on a plane and gotten there that
quickly then that's usually they're like
spoofing a device or ip sometimes those
are interesting factors but yeah if you
feed enough of these in um
you will oh oh the another fun one is
like
you know real users will type their
credit card like one number at a time
yeah scammers have a list of them and
they'll just paste in a whole a whole
number
um so you can look at like the the
number of milliseconds between
keystrokes like there's all kinds of
stuff people have come up with you for
travel velocity you could probably
incorporate vpns too because there's
probably
a
travel velocity for vpn switching too
that's human-like like if you're using
legitimately vpn for something else yeah
um that that might be there's like
legitimate uses too actually you know i
feel embarrassed that i don't know this
probably should but the i'm not a robot
capture thing capture thing yeah so that
probably works in the same way like how
do you move your mouse maybe or how the
dynamics of the clicking totally
but how does that even work that well
then and why can't it be fake i need to
look into this because it's it's such a
trivial captcha it feels like should be
very crackable and yet a lot of high
security places use that yeah it's
really interesting it's another cat and
mouse game so i think they've yeah but
it's using a lot of similar signals like
mouse movements um keystrokes and then
obviously all the stuff that comes over
the
the wire with your browser so like
what operating system what fonts you
know what headers are being sent over
and yeah um there's actually there's an
old website a camera was called it was
kind of like panoptix click or
panopticon or something but it basically
was like a proof of concept site that um
they would just show you all the data
that was kind of getting sent over with
your your request and like
say that there's only one person in the
world who has this exact set of data
it's you and so it's almost like um
a work around a clever workaround to
track somebody
um make identify a unique person even if
like there wasn't a cookie involved or
something yeah this is a fascinating
world where you can't see anybody you're
in the dark
and yet you have a lot of signal you
have to figure out who's the real person
who's not who's a robot who's not yeah
uh let me step back we're gonna jump
around all over the place step back
that's why i like your interviews you
get into like technical topics
so so uh just let's use bitcoin as a
measure of time
you started coinbase when bitcoin was
ten dollars
yeah um
and you just mentioned an incredible
system with security with transactions
everything is thought through there's a
lot going on but what was version one
back in those early days the first
prototype of coinbase what did that look
like yeah like what what did it take to
write it
to think through it
and and uh make it work enough to at
least make you believe that it's gonna
work
well i definitely didn't know if it was
gonna work i mean it was kind of i felt
like i was just
following my gut so
i mean i was working at airbnb i was a
software engineer there
project manager i was working on some
fraud prevention stuff for instance
and um i read the bitcoin white paper in
kind of december of 2010
i started going to some bitcoin meetups
in the bay area
met lots of interesting people there
like crazy people anarchists you know
like really brilliant people all the
above and
so i started nights and weekends trying
to hack put together a prototype and my
initial thought was
well you know smtp is a protocol that
runs email and
you know git is is a protocol for
version control that and but people made
like gmail and github they don't most
people don't want to run their own email
server or even their own git server they
just want to like use a hosted thing
that you know will do all the security
and backups for them
so the thought in my head at that time
was bitcoin's this new protocol there's
probably going to be somebody who makes
a hosted service that does all the
security and backups for you makes
bitcoin as a protocol easy to use
so maybe i should
maybe i should make like a hosted
bitcoin wallet or something that would
that was my it was going to make gmail
for bitcoin or something
and a bunch of people told me that was a
bad idea like bunch most of my smart
friends who i told about it they were
like
well first of all i don't really get
what you're doing at all like bitcoin
sounds like a scam or something you got
you've gotten involved in um
but then other people who understood
what bitcoin was told me i thought it
was a dumb idea because they're like
dude if you store all this bitcoin
you're just gonna get hacked like nobody
you know
why would you why would you do that and
so i i kind of had this thought like you
know what i'm not gonna go all in and
like make a story everyone's bitcoin
that would be too much right now i have
a job i have a day job you know um but
let me just make a prototype and i'll
tell people this is like a beta thing
like don't put any real money in it and
just see if there's interest and if i
feel like i'm onto something maybe i'll
go do this as a company because i did i
really wanted to be an entrepreneur at
that time i was like
i was 29 i was almost turning 30 and i
was i always wanted to like start a
company but
i was
i was you know i wasn't yet i was an
employee at a company that was great but
so anyway i had this prototype i was
hacking together nice and weekends i
actually wrote a whole bitcoin node in
ruby which turned out to be a maybe a
weird decision in hindsight because ruby
wasn't the most performant language
we've subsequently had to rebuild that
many times but
yeah i had this hosted bitcoin wallet
and the thing that i didn't have any
users for it by the way i applied to y
combinator because i was like maybe if
somebody there writes me a check this
will like make it feel like a real
company and i was trying to find i was
trying to find a co-founder at that time
unsuccessfully
so i was basically just wandering in the
desert i had a lot of self-doubt about
this because i i was like i don't know
all my friends don't think's just kind
of dumb and
maybe bitcoin is just going to get shut
down and like this all be some stupid
thing so
there was definitely a feeling of just
wandering lost in the desert lots of
self-doubt
um paul graham and the y combinator
group kind of wrote me the first check
after i went and interviewed and stuff
and they they wrote me a check for like
150k and that was the first time
somebody who i really looked up to kind
of said this is this is worth pursuing
like maybe maybe you're onto something
maybe or not but like let's at least try
it
and so i that was kind of what gave me
the confidence to quit my job and try it
and
um i'll wrap the story here by saying
that like we i you know i found the
right co-founder after y combinator
we still didn't have any customers the
thing that you know i basically launched
the hosted bitcoin wallet
there were people signing up um i just
posted on reddit and places like that
and you know maybe like 100 people would
sign up and then nobody would come back
and so i was like i just in y comment do
they often tell you like
you know talk to your customers and
improve your product talk to your
customers improve your product that's
all you're supposed to be doing try to
find product market fit so i emailed
like five of the users that had signed
up
and i was like hey i worked on this app
i saw you signed up can i get on the
phone with you i get on the phone with
like five of these folks
and i was like you know why didn't you
come back and the guy was like well the
app was okay for a for a beta but um
like i don't have any bitcoins so i
didn't really know what to do with it
and i remember this light bulb kind of
went off my head i was like well if i
put a buy bitcoin button in there
uh would you have used it and he was
like yeah maybe
so then i had this we went about the
process my co-founder at that time we
like got
basically had to get like a bank
partnership payment rails you know an
exchange basic exchange functionality
all that stuff i was mentioning earlier
in place
and the minute we launched that feature
where you could just click buy put in
your bank counter credit card buy it buy
bitcoin it showed up in your account
from that day forward like the number of
users started go up like this and so we
finally had found product market fit
after two years of laundering in the
desert so you weren't even thinking
about to buy the
on-ramps you would think it would be
just a wall a place to store bitcoin
you've already gotten
yeah okay this is i mean uh because
that's such a pain to do
to have to work with others
to convert dollars of any fiat currency
into
into bitcoin yeah so did you
i mean were you uh
overwhelmed by the immensity of the task
here or were you just
um
sort of not allowing yourself to think
too deeply through this whole thing and
just letting the optimism take over here
you know i was really looking forward to
like doing something crazy and like a
big challenge and um i wanted to
i i love kind of
crisis moments like that where you know
i'm very determined right especially
when i i get like very set on something
and i'm just like you know what i'm
gonna figure out a way to make this
[ __ ] thing work like no matter what
and so
i i reveled in that i i was sort of i
had i had read all these books about
startups and like every startup has
these like you know major setbacks and
just like nothing works and so
that was a sign that you're doing
something right i had no idea if i was
doing anything right at all but i was
like i was kind of loving the experience
of it in a weird way it felt
it felt stressful at the time like you
know nothing was working and
but i was just i felt like i was
on the right path somehow and so i just
kept going i don't know
um
what was the darkest moment that you've
gone to in your mind during that time
what was what were some of the tougher
moments you said self-doubt
yeah
have you uh yeah where where'd you go
where'd you go in your mind
[Laughter]
is there a moment where you're just like
laying there this is this is hopeless
well
there's a couple moments i'm remembering
i mean
so
for whatever reason i had this like big
chip on my shoulder at that time and i
was like
i really want to do something important
in the world like
you know i could have a good life and
like work for some good companies and
write some software and i'm
for some reason i never wanted that for
myself that probably would have been
healthier honestly just to like that as
an expected value outcome that's
probably
a better thing in life but i was like
i was like man i really want to do
something important and have a bigger
impact and i was like
i was willing to sacrifice a lot for
that i was like
sleep and not going out with friends and
stuff i remember one of the just for
like years working on this stuff
remember
one of the darker moments was um
we probably had like maybe five
employees at that time
and
i remember like a bunch of bad things
happened like all at once and it was so
first of all
you have to remember at this time
we were all very sleep deprived which
kind of exacerbates everything if you
look at like the exxon valdez spell
spill and all these like natural
disasters like sleep deprivation is
often involved
so because the reason why we're so sleep
deprived is not just because we were
working so much but
like the site would go offline in the
middle of the night and we'd get i get
paged i was like on pager duty so i'd
get woken up sometimes like two or three
times a night like have to try to fix
something go back to sleep
so
in that environment you can kind of get
you can get discouraged
so one bad thing that happened was
we had a bug on the website and
there were thousands of people on reddit
and twitter who were all
like pissed at coinbase because like the
balances were showing wrong and they
were just like
you know [ __ ] this company it's over
like i hate these guys and so
that was i'd never had this feeling of a
thousand people mad at me at the same
time you know i feel like i'm a pretty
chill guy like most time people don't
get mad at me so that was one another
one was that um can we pause on that
that's so interesting so you you were
saying like here's a dream i'm trying to
create something and now forever the
reputation of this dream is ruined
it will never it's irrecoverable it's
over that kind of feeling yeah well i
didn't you're right i didn't know at
that time i was like is this is this the
end like
everybody we're so we're so tiny now
everybody hates us so is it over yeah um
yeah nobody told me this before starting
a company that like you're a bunch of
people hate you for this which is like a
very counterintuitive thing because
you know if most companies i think are
doing good things in the world at least
you're trying right and so even if
someone's like trying but they're not
they're failing i'm generally rooting
for them at least you're trying right
yeah but
that's not the case at all and most
founders i've known
have gone through this too where um
they're very surprised at the amount of
hate that they get and if it's i think
it's actually like a muscle you can
build your tolerance to it like
because
you know you go talk to somebody who's
like for you it feels terrible because
you're at the center of this storm and
like but if you go then you go talk to
like you know your family or some other
person like dude i didn't even hear
about that like my they're just busy in
their own life and so they
they have no idea that you had all this
negative press or like whatever it was
can i
once again put lingard on that yeah
there's an interesting
person i'd like to bring up just as an
example
uh bill gates yeah
so he gets a very large amount of hate
on the internet yeah and
there's something about him this is me
talking that you that he seems out of
touch about that hate
he i i believe at least in my
understanding that uh with the resources
he has
he's trying and is actually doing a lot
of good
and yet there's a gigantic amount of
hate conspiracy theories and stuff like
that right and it feels like that's the
case
because he's somehow out of touch
with with people so i wonder how you
stay in touch with the voice of the
people without being destroyed
by the outrage is there is there any
wisdom you have to that or not
i don't know about wisdom but i've
thought about this too because
yeah you want to always be
open to feedback especially from people
who have like your best interests at
heart right and if you can become
isolated from it and just like you know
surrounded by yes people and um
i mean who knows maybe maybe like
she and putin and people like that are
in situations i have no idea
but if you listen to too much of it and
you just try to please everyone you'll
never get anything done and i mean most
of the best leaders
are people
who
they can act when they believe that they
they're doing something net positive for
the world and humanity and they actually
don't really care if they piss off some
proportion of the people
almost anything you're going to do of
significance in the world today is going
to piss off five percent of people maybe
maybe 49 of people or whatever maybe 60
i don't know so
you never want to become so surrounded
by people who just work for you and will
say yes and then you think like well i'm
a genius and i'm like i'm a that's how
you become a dictator or whatever
um but you also can't care so much about
what people think because then you'll
never do anything that's truly authentic
to yourself
one other thought on that by the way i
think it's a really good question
so i've thought about this a lot like
why
you know people generally kind of hate
on zuck and they hate on bill gates and
they hate on um
they don't really hate on elon actually
has a lot of haters too but it's a
different thing this is measured this is
measured i was looking at some surveys
so i think
uh zuck is the most so loved and hated
right yeah uh zuckerberg is the most
both uh loved and hated he's the most
hated and then i think it's bill gates
and elon is down there i think it's like
uh 40 percent
hey zuck people asked and then elon is
in the double digits but low double
digits and so it's interesting you you
just look at this ask yourself why
right so i ask myself this sometimes too
because
i don't claim to know any of these
people well but like i've i've met them
briefly and i my impression is that
they're actually all smart people trying
to do good things in the world so
there's not too much difference there
despite public presumption perception so
why is it that some are really hated
some aren't i mean
it's a complicated question um obviously
you know zuck and his facebook got
blamed for the whole election thing and
all that didn't help um social media has
gotten a lot of pressure just from like
you know hey why aren't you solving all
of society's tough problems it's like
well they're just one company
but one thing i've noticed is that
you know a lot of these people they're a
little they have like asperger's right a
little bit and um sometimes
you know people with aspergers don't
really emote in the same way and so i
think it's almost a form of like um
um
like
bias against um
their cognitive
type or something which is like that
person doesn't emote right i don't trust
their in their intentions
and um
the other thing i've thought about too
is that sometimes i think some leaders
you know um like maybe zak or bill gates
they can come across as like a little
bit
pr rehearsed like they're basically um
they're giving the pr approved answers
as where elon just says whatever he
thinks like to a fault so even if people
hate what he says they're like at least
i believe it's authentic
so i've always thought about that too
for myself i'm like how do i
you can you can [ __ ] it up on both sides
right like if you just come out and
you're like saying whatever's stream of
consciousness
you'll often end up like pissing off
people on your team or like saying
tripping over some like regulation that
you you know
um there's all kinds of things about
running a public company you know you
can't say certain stuff
but if you're too pr approved and your
answer is like nobody trusts you what
you're saying and so anyway this is
something i think about a lot i don't
think i have the right answer but i'm
trying to i'm trying to find that yeah
and more and more with the internet
there's a premium on authenticity just
like you're saying yeah people really
really appreciate that so for leaders
it's a challenge to be how do i
uh make sure i'm authentic but also
um don't say stupid [ __ ] yeah and so
that's an interesting thing i've noticed
that um just having interacted with the
with a bunch of leaders
that
you have to be careful how much you
surround yourself with pr folks
because the best i would say let me just
say a nice thing about marketing and pr
folks the best
marketing folks are extremely good yeah
so they understand exactly what great
marketing is and get great pr it's
authenticity it's showing revealing the
beauty as opposed to uh pr and marketing
out of fear oh don't say that don't say
this don't that
because then you you start living in
this kind of that pushes you towards a
bubble where you can't express the we
your your beautiful quirks and weirdness
and all that kind of stuff and also
the cool the beautiful things about what
you're doing i find like um especially
with the tech thing like even like
coinbase
the way to reveal the beauty of it
is not only by showing all the things
you could do with it but showing that
there's great engineering going on
underneath so letting the nerds shine
too it doesn't have to be like
uh
these kind of commercials where it's
like uh
a happy family using uh coinbase to send
a transaction about uh flowers for mom
or something like that like it could be
also like gritty stuff and real stuff so
um
that's a general just observation i made
but you said you were talking about dark
moments and that there's people on the
internet yeah they were pissed off that
the site was down and you said there
might be something else
yeah so sleep deprived like a bunch of
people on the internet were pissed at me
the balances were [ __ ] up like people
were tweeting the company's over just
give the money back
whatever
and then um
oh yeah somebody posted
so we had all this we didn't we started
all these customer support inquiries and
like we only had
like a few people at the company and so
we were backed up maybe like 20 20 000
support requests so people couldn't get
a hold of us
so somebody posted my cell phone number
on
reddit and they were like they're like
if you need to get a hold of the ceo
whatever because everyone's upset about
where their money is
so i remember we're in the office it's
like it's like late at night we've been
working like 12 hours we're all sleep
deprived i'm trying to i'm trying to
hack and like get this bug fixed
and we all need like food at the office
and so my phone my phone has been
blowing up all day because someone
posted my phone number on the internet
and there's like a guy um
there was a guy like trying to deliver
food and i needed to answer my phone to
like get the food from downstairs so i
was like [ __ ] i gotta just see who if
that's him so i start answering the call
and it's like
is this brian i'm like no wrong number
click you know and i you know i the next
i pick up the next call it's like every
every when i finish the call another
call is like coming in so i was like
this i'm a reporter from japan like
asking about a security nope wrong
number click and i like finally get the
delivery guy downstairs bring the food
up we were all like you know surviving
to like fix this bug
um
i remember there was just basically a
point that night where i was like [ __ ] i
need to just i basically just curled up
on a and like a ball on the floor
and i i just like cried for a little bit
um i think i let myself just kind of
wallow and self-pity kind of took a nap
for about five minutes and i was like
let's [ __ ] solve this and i like you
know stop being like a little whatever
and like got back up
deprivation combined with just the
stress and the pressure of the site
going down and everybody wants you the
site to be up just the pressure from
people and the number of users is
growing and growing and growing so that
pressure is just mentally mentally tough
yeah
what was your source of strength during
that time
like what like uh
somebody that patted you on the back and
said we got this yeah well it definitely
helped to have a co-founder so
you know there's like that old saying
about it's better to be in a great
relationship than to be single but it's
better to be single than a bad
relationship so
co-founders actually blow up a lot of
companies too but when you find the
right co-founder which i was lucky to
find with with fred ursum
that was very important there was
definitely moments where
you know i was like
kind of you know
at the wit's end or whatever and he was
like
it's like dude let's rally like and he
basically carried the team you know a
couple times like in really key moments
what advice would you give to startup
founders about this particular stage
about surviving it
to the five and through the five
employee stage where you yeah well if
your pre-product market fit
the best advice that i have from that
period is
um action produces information so just
just like keep doing stuff you know i
remember like um
paul
is a good life yeah paul graham had this
great line like that i think that's his
line and he he was like startups are
like sharks if they stop swimming
swimming they die you know so even if
you're like not sure what to do like
just do anything because when you do it
it'll like it'll produce some
information like people liked it they
didn't this was very true for me there
was times where
i just did something
um
instead of debating it endlessly and
like just try it you know like all right
so we shipped it and like there was a
couple times where like the minute i
shipped it
and i was like i knew i know we we built
this wrong but now i have an idea of
what to do next and it wasn't i only
would have had that idea if we had
actually gone through the exercise of
going to build it it's like
my other favorite analogy for this is
that
you're like at the base of a mountain
that's shrouded in fog
and you're looking up at the mountain
and you're trying to think like okay how
do i get up there but you can only see
like three or four steps ahead because
the fog is so thick
so you have to just take steps into the
unknown
and
when you take three steps another three
steps will be revealed ahead of you and
sometimes you'll end up on some local
maximum you'll have to retrace your
steps or whatever but or come up to a
cliff you know but um
most people in life don't take the steps
into the fog into the unknown because
it's scary or they're like i don't know
what if i fail or like i don't know how
that's gonna work or i might run out of
money or i won't be able to get a job
after or
i don't know whatever reason but that
that is like one of the things that
separates i think entrepreneurial people
with that kind of inclination is that
they have sort of a comfort with this
risk tolerance but it's actually not
really risky if you think about it it's
not like
you know in at least in most um places
like you know if you go to if you go to
a startup and it fails like you're gonna
you're even more valuable to your next
employer right or you can go raise a
seed round pay yourself a salary
try it for like two years or three years
if it doesn't work go get another job
it's not like you're you weren't paying
yourself a salary during that time so i
think i think people overestimate the
risk of doing a startup and they just
never they never start because
it seems crazy and all your friends
think it's silly like that's sort of the
default nature of every big startup idea
it's just basic fear it's the same kind
of fear that if you see a if you're a
guy see a cute girl at a bar it's the
fear associated with coming up to her
yeah you like her asking her it's like
what's the actual risk exactly right um
she'll say i'm no thanks i'm not no
thanks and i i guess the risk is like
that's going to be mentally difficult
to deal with rejection so just like it's
mentally difficult to deal with failure
if you if you had a bunch of ideas and
you were excited about them and you
implement them and you realize
they're not good that could be difficult
to to keep pushing through that but i
suppose that's life you're supposed to
you know perseverance through the
failures yeah and then the risk is low
so that's and then the whole time
through the fog up the mountain you're
looking for product market fit yeah
that's right so you know you have it
when the usage of your product keeps
growing without any marketing dollars or
anything like that it's just like more
people keep coming back every week or
month so you're kind of keep you're
basically watching your stats
nothing is working
you see these little wiggles of false
hope in your metrics
and you basically just keep talking to
customers fixing the improving the
product talk to customers improve the
product talk to customers
you know and trying to run out of money
so be really scrappy
and then if you're lucky you hit some
kind of threshold where like okay the
thing is good enough now or we hit on
some use case and then it'll
organically start to grow a bit
and then then you have a whole different
set of problems once you hit product
market fit which is
how do we scale this thing how do we
hire people
how do we
you know
hire an executive team or raise more
money and like so the problems totally
change but um
you're
there through the whole thing so that's
the other question that's fascinating
again back to the girl at the bar how do
you hire people it's like
how do you find good friends
how do you find good relationships
and in this specific case how do you
hire good people engineers
executive
all of it one thing is i've done a lot
of reps on hiring at this point so um
coinbase has about 5 000 people
um probably the first 500 people or
something maybe in that range um you
know i i interviewed every single one of
those but you have to remember there's
probably like
i don't know on average maybe 10 people
that we
went in the process for every one we
hired or something so it was like
by the time that we had 500 employees i
had done like 5 000 interviews or
something i was like very burned out in
interviews i had been doing
i had some days i did like seven
interviews in a day or maybe um
you know you've been you would do lots
of interviews maybe you wouldn't get
burned out but different kind of
interviews uh very different very
different yeah very different because
you're
uh
so first of all most of your interviews
lead to rejection yeah
which is also exhausting
yeah and there's a whole there's a whole
part of the interview which is about
candidate experience right sometimes you
know it's not the right person but you
want to make sure they have a good
experience like if you're just exhausted
and you're on your sixth interview and
you're like well thanks for coming in
and you wrap and you just and then like
you're gonna create a detractor someone
is out there like [ __ ] that company or
brian was rude to me or whatever so i
had to honestly i had to work on that a
little bit in the early days i was doing
so many interviews like i needed to make
sure that
um when people came in i was like you
know made them feel comfortable
um
asked him a couple of like warm-up
questions just like how how was it
getting in the office like did you find
it okay and like what have you been up
to this week and not just like
you know like a factory assembly line
like boom boom boom like
yeah but also there's a moment because
i've interviewed a bunch of people for
like teams and stuff yeah there's also a
moment when you early on no it's not
gonna be a good fit yeah and you still
have to land that plane and yeah and all
that kind of stuff and that could get
really really really exhausting so yeah
anyway sorry so
yeah so basically we tried all we've
tried so many things over the years to
make interviews more efficient because
it's a huge time sync for um the team
so
you know we we basically will usually
get them down to like 25 minutes
i've seen if you're trying to hire like
a big team let's say
um
you know of people who are like
contractors or something not necessarily
full-time employees i've seen people
actually do 10-minute interviews
you can even interview like a thousand
people almost like in a week or
something i'm not sure if that quite
works out but let me a little less than
that but you can basically get six and
six done in an hour if you're just i
need to get a team of 30 contractors for
whatever purpose but if you're talking
about full-time employees i usually do
like 25 minute
you know you're oftentimes like
one one thing we've done is we'll put
like a
um
like a google form online and it's like
put some basic hurdles in there like you
know ask them
um
to put in an answer which you can check
in a spreadsheet if it was correct or
not and like there were some funny
examples in the early days of coinbase
where we put in like brain teasers and
stuff but we don't do that anymore we do
like normal interviews we do references
the kinds of things i ask in interviews
um
you know it's usually like
i like to think about what what do we
need this person to accomplish in this
role right
and
get really specific about that it's like
usually something pretty hard and then
i'll ask them a question it's like tell
me about a time you did x
and um
or tell me about the hardest the hardest
kind of problem you've had to solve in
why
and what did you do specifically to
overcome it right
so i'm asking to see if they can
actually do the stuff we need to get
done but then i'm also kind of asking
inter like culture questions if i'm
interviewing for that
and so i'm trying to see like are they
concise communicators can they just give
me a clear
answer
and stop talking some people like ramble
on for like five ten minutes if you ask
the first question some people are you
know their interrupter like church of
interruption so like they won't stop
talking until you interrupt them which
for me i know i'm always patient and i
wait so yeah that's weird
i'm looking to see for humility too like
you know i'll tell ask people well tell
me about a time something went really
wrong like you had conflict or someone
on a team or
um and what i'm kind of looking for is
were they part of the solution or are
they still holding on to like blame and
criticism about that and be like well i
told them it shouldn't do that way but
they didn't listen to me you know these
are all like bad signs so i'm looking
for yeah can they get the job done will
they work together on a team
can they communicate effectively
do they fit into our cultural values and
you know those kind of things yeah i
mean there's uh because i've
uh even even for help with this this
podcast here but also at mit and so on
i've done a bunch of hiring and uh i was
always looking for you said brain
teasers all kinds of simple questions
that can
that can reveal a lot of information
and it's always been challenging i used
to i still asked this question but
uh
do you think it's better to work hard or
work smart
and
you know i had this idea
that
i've that i think i've matured about
which is i kind of believe that people
who say work smart on that question
don't actually work smart so the right
textbook answers what it's better to
work smart
but the reality is it's
it's people that haven't actually ever
done anything that
say work smart they're like
they haven't really struggled because my
general belief at the time
was in order to discover
what it means to
work smart to be efficient to you have
to work your ass off so you have to
really fail a lot and failure feels like
hard work
and so i was always suspicious of people
that would say work smart i would want
to interrogate that question
um but then i also you know have have
learned that there is
people that are just exceptionally um
exceptionally efficient
they really do know what it means to
work smart even at a young age
and so like you can't just disqualify
based on that you have to dig in deeper
but some of the most interesting people
i've ever worked with would say work
hard unapologetically and they're
usually the ones that know how to be
efficient which is it's just an
interesting thing like that and and i've
always searched for questions of that
nature to see
can i can i get
can i get a person to reveal something
profound about them
in as brief of a question as possible
and i you know and then of course
there's basic attention to detail and
brain teasers and stuff like that
depending on the role programming and so
on to see can they can they solve a
tricky puzzle
and do so like one that doesn't require
a lot of effort but requires a certain
um non-linear way of thinking is there
is there some
i mean maybe you don't want to reveal
but is there some questions
that you sometimes find yourself leaning
on
you said like how did you solve
a hard problem in your past
and have them talk through it that's one
you know we started with brain teasers
periodically at coinbase and i we got we
got away from that relatively quickly
and i think
one i it's a tough one because i
actually think
it does show how somebody
kind of performs under pressure but it's
i don't think it's a super reliable
indicator because there's some people
who are really
good
in what the typical work situation but
that's not a typical work situation
where somebody puts you on the spot like
in a live interview and sometimes people
get nervous and they can't think clearly
and like they don't have their computer
in front of them or whatever they
normally use
so
yeah i i'm a little skeptical now of the
of the brain teaser thing um
there is a whole
yeah
there is a whole question about like a
lot of universities are getting rid of
you know entrance exams so if you're
hiring right out of universities um
sometimes it's becoming a less reliable
indicator of like are they in that
university and i've heard some companies
we haven't done this yet but i've heard
some companies are actually creating
their own like for college grads like
their own um basically
exams like standardized testing almost
to get people in the door because the
degree almost like doesn't mean what it
used to which is the whole topic but
yeah that's fascinating because um
it's fascinating both for that because
it's not just about you trying to hire a
great team it's also to help them find
the right place to work at yeah
just like it's like a two-way street
um
all right so once you found the
the product market fit
how did coinbase become what it is today
so
let me ask on an engineering question
actually sort of
uh from the the ruby wallet days
what are some of the interesting
challenges there or are they not
engineering just the the things that had
to be solved uh what were they
engineering
regulation
um
financial hiring lawyers
what was it
so post product market fit yeah a lot of
it's scaling and you got to build up
build out an actual company so
i remember i was still writing a lot of
code there for a while and we were we
were hiring in we had like maybe 25
people or something i remember one of
our investors came by one day and he was
like brian how much your time are you
spending writing code i was like
maybe maybe 50 or something he was like
how much time are you spending hiring
people i was like probably 20
and he was like
i think you need to flip those numbers
like this company's not gonna scale
you're the ceo you don't need to be
writing code every day
you're gonna have to transition that
stuff like even if people can't all that
stuff's locked in your head so maybe
they're not gonna do it as well as you
for the first six months or something
but like if you don't start to
transition it you're never gonna build a
real company it's just gonna be
you're gonna be the bottleneck
so you know like a lot of founders
that took me a while to like really
internalize that lesson i'd always heard
people say that and you know
but i still was holding on too much to
decision making and i probably still am
by the way like even to this day at
coinbase where
we uh continually have to push down
decision making in the org like even
with 5000 people like who are the owners
of each of these things and so the
temptation is people to push it up and
you become a bottleneck and anyway
um so yeah you want you basically need
to make sure you have enough money where
you don't die
if there's in some some kind of a
downturn or hit break even profitability
we were in a position where we were
periodically profitable during up
periods but then crypto would go down
and we were unprofitable and so we had
to kind of manage our own psychology and
the balance sheet to make sure we didn't
like die in the downturn which a lot of
crypto companies did
um we had to basically professionalize a
whole bunch of services that had been
just very quickly thrown together by
like 20 year olds right
whether that was cyber security it's
like okay how do you get like a really
senior experienced cyber security person
but not someone who's so senior that
they can't get their hands dirty and
they can come into a company with 25 50
people how do you get a finance person
to come and do that our finances were
a mess like we didn't even really know
how much money we had at certain times
and stuff i mean this was it's
embarrassing to say but it was true like
i remember
there was a point where um
we had raised i think like
our series c or something like that and
i think we had our bank accounts i just
put like 25 million dollars like in a
different bank account that none of this
stuff was touched to the actual
operation the business because i was
like
you know our operations were so messy
and we needed to hire a new finance
person and i was like this i heard
horror stories of actually startups
where they thought they had x amount of
money
and then it turned out they had way less
and then the whole thing was insolvent
in like three weeks so you wanted to
have some padding until yes like all
right i can't at least count on this to
save us if we go to like super negative
right i mean it was like a cheap hack
but that was like the only thing they
could come up with and you know until we
could hire like a real cfo and financial
team who like
okay now we got our arms around how much
cash we have it sounds silly but we had
such high
volume of money coming in and out anyway
what was the ordering of hiring by the
way
like uh
how many engineers was it early on you
said cfo was not did you even have a cfo
for a bit yeah like what was the
the landscape of hiring as you building
up this company
was it engineering focused
well let's see i mean so the first
person we hired was just like
we need we need to solve customer
support so we brought someone to do that
because we were all staying up till
midnight every night trying to do
customer support and then
we got more engineers and then i think
maybe the sixth hire or something like
that was a recruiter because that that
turned out to be you you need to build
hire the person who can hire more people
yeah that turned out to be a great
forced multiplier and then
man you go on down the list eventually
you want to hire some more senior people
um we needed legal and compliance we
needed that really badly because we you
know there's all kinds of questions
about what the legality of it was was it
hard to find legal people that work with
crypto like serious adults
because it's such a cutting-edge new
world yeah i mean there was nobody who
had like more than
nobody had three years of experience
with it because it had only been around
a year so yeah we were finding people
from adjacent fields
there's a certain personality type of
people who are willing to join early
companies because they have no structure
you can't really commit to them about
you're going to have this team or this
boss or whatever like everything's in
chaos and flux
so
it takes
yeah hiring is one of the hardest things
in the early stage for sure you got to
find people crazy enough to join you on
this journey
so one of the interesting things about
coinbase and you've written we've talked
we'll talk about it a bit you're very
focused on the mission yeah yeah you're
very kind of
i think that simplifies things that
makes
that makes hiring easier that makes
working a coinbase easier that makes
yeah i mean it's similar sort of elon
has the same thing it's pretty clear
it's pretty clear what we're here to do
yeah so
i suppose what's the mission
of coinbase
well it's to increase economic freedom
in the world and what is economic
freedom
yeah so economic freedom is this term
kind of like gdp that economists use and
it's basically a measure of different
countries around the world it looks at
things like are there property rights in
forest is there free trade is the
currency stable can you start companies
that you want to start and can you join
the ones you want to join and you know
is there corruption and bribery
prevalent or is it relatively free of
that
and so
this there's several different
organizations that basically score
countries by economic freedom and the
really cool thing about economic freedom
is that
basically it positively correlates with
things that we all want in society like
um not only higher growth of the economy
but also things like higher
self-reported happiness of citizens
better treatment of the environment
better income for the poorest ten
percent of people
and it negatively correlates with things
we don't want in society like corruption
and bribery and war even and things like
that and so it's this pretty pretty
crazy provocative idea which is that
if you give people good
property rights and rule of law and
allow them to trade
it basically encourages them to do more
good stuff and the whole society
benefits like one of the things you know
you may have noticed this
growing up in various places you did or
you know i spent a year living in buenos
aires argentina that went through
hyperinflation and
there's a certain like pessimism that
can creep into
countries when they don't have
economic freedom which it's basically
like everyone has this bit of this vibe
which is like don't stick your head up
you know don't try too hard because it
could all be gone tomorrow like the
things that really are valuable in life
are just
family and friends and the past was
better than the future will be and
and so you don't really people don't try
as many they don't try hard because
you're not really sure you can actually
keep the upside of your labor if you if
you try hard so you just don't try as
hard whereas in america historically um
you know or high economic freedom
countries
you know people
basically like they just try more stuff
because they're like if i do good for
other people i'll get to keep part of it
for myself and i can improve my lot in
life and for my children my community
whatever
so
i realized when i read the bitcoin white
paper a long time ago
that at least i had a hunch at the time
i was like this might be a really
powerful piece of technology that can
inject
good financial infrastructure into all
these countries around the world that
don't have it basically good economic
freedom principles in like you know
property rights and things like that
into these countries all over the world
with just as long as you had a
smartphone and now crypto got invented
we could everybody could have economic
freedom and it's crypto is kind of
really well suited for economic freedom
because
if you want property rights it's based
like crypto is if you can remember a 12
word phrase or
you know have an app on your phone you
can store as much wealth as you want and
it can't be taken away from you you can
even
you know there's like refugees who need
to flee and they want to take their
wealth with them and they can't do it
often in the traditional financial
system and so
crypto lets them do that right crypto's
inherently global so it allows free
trade and cross-border payments
um it makes it easy to accept payments
from people globally you know it's it
provides a stable currency to everyone
not only with bitcoin which is kind of
like this new reserve currency but
um also with stable coins right which
are you know new new inventions there so
yeah i basically feel like crypto is
is this secret hiding in plain sight
that can create economic freedom for
people all over the world and a more
fair and free and global economy
well so the limit and by the way i
didn't know about argentina why'd you
end up in argentina
okay so i was basically um
you know i was living in houston texas
after college where i went to school and
i had never studied abroad um
i kind of like
i don't know i felt like i needed some
adventure or something in my life and i
was like i was running this other
startup that i was trying at the time a
tutoring company and i could i could
work from anywhere so my plan was you
know what i'm just gonna go
do like a month in every city around
south america just be like almost like
to force myself out of my comfort zone
because i
i had never traveled by myself to a
foreign country or whatever and where i
didn't really speak the language and
anyway i i landed in buenos aires
thinking i'd go all around south america
where i had never been there but i
basically once i was set up in south in
in buenos aires with an apartment and a
cell phone and stuff then i was like i
want to do that all again next month so
i just stayed there for most of the time
and took some day trips but
but yeah it was kind of a formative
experience in that regard you got a
chance sort of unexpectedly to
experience the the social effects of
hyperinflation which is interesting but
i also i've i've never been i really
really want to go as a person who likes
tango as a person who likes
the argentinian national team in soccer
yeah and uh
and and steak
all right uh
and all the other things that argentina
is known for okay so um
economic freedom one of the limits on
economic freedom comes from government
and government regulations and all those
kinds of things throughout the world
um so how does cryptocurrency help
resist that so can you sort of elaborate
a little bit further
what are the things that limit economic
freedom and how does
crypto help
ease that
you know
today the world like traditional
financial system is basically every
country of the world for the most part
has their own currency
and so there's a group of people or
institutions in each of those countries
that's controlling
that economic policy or that money
supply
and
you know it can be
it can be manipulated right so
it's not like many of these currencies
are not linked to gold standard you know
the u.s kind of famously came off that
in the 1970s for instance but if you
read ray dalio and all this stuff like
he talks about there's thousands of fiat
currencies that have been in existence
over time
and
basically all of them eventually get
disconnected from um backing of like
hard commodities
and then they get over inflated and
printed and so
in times of stress
um you know with nixon i guess it was
like in the u.s it was the vietnam war
or something like that it kind of drove
government spending and so under times
of stress they say hey it's a temporary
measure we need to break the peg um
temporary was like you know famous words
that he used and um
and they go they go like they go print
and so the bad thing about that of
course is that it sort of erodes
people's like wealth if they can only
hold their assets in cash which
basically like poor people tend to do
that
you know if you're wealthy you can hold
um stocks or like real estate and things
like that but so it's a really attacks
on the poorest people in society
inflation so anyway crypto in in a way
is a little bit of like um a return to
the gold standard in this digital era
right bitcoin there's guaranteed
scarcity of it it's deflationary there's
never going to be more than 21 million
bitcoin
and so that's that's a really
important principle
um
i also think bic you know not just
bitcoin but like cryptocurrency
generally
it's really important in terms of this
um you asked about regulation right so
think about like
if you wanted to make a global um
borrowing and lending marketplace or a
global exchange
you would have to go to all 200
countries in the world sometimes like
maybe 50 states in the u.s and get
lending licenses or an
operating exchange or whatever
and
you know
they're not gonna that's just an
incredible amount of work and you can't
even do business in many of these
countries because like you know you have
to bribe somebody or it's corrupt or
whatever
and so
but with defy with decentralized finance
people have published um you know like
uniswap is a decentralized exchange
everybody in the world no matter what
country you're in what jurisdiction can
i can interface with that decentralized
exchange because it and there's no
central
um company operating it it's it's a it's
a it's a smart contract on the ethereum
blockchain which is globally
decentralized so there's no throat to
choke there's no one person you can or a
company you can go to to like hey shut
this thing down even if everybody who's
working on unit swap today stopped
the us the unit swap smart contract
would continue to operate on the
ethereum blockchain um similarly for
like a borrowing lending marketplace you
know like
it's
you know if you want somebody in india
wants to borrow from somebody in the u.s
or whatever like there's very difficult
to do that in the traditional financial
world
but in a smart contract that's
decentralized
you can enable anybody to access it so
it's it's really kind of this great
democratizing force
that is creating a new financial system
that is more fair and more free
um
yeah and in some ways it is um
it's a it's a clever it's a clever way
that's
not yeah it's it's enabling people to do
that in a novel way so is unit swap in
some sense a competitor coinbase in
which way is it and which way is it not
so because
for people who don't know
coinbase is centralized
so let me ask uh
doesn't that go against the spirit of
crypto since kryptos is is decentralized
what are the pros and cons of being
centralized as an exchange
so i don't think coinbase is fully
centralized there we have many different
products and the way that i think about
it is that
our exchange
or our brokerage is a
centralized regulated financial service
business and it's actually important for
the crypto ecosystem to have that
because you want to
allow a lot of the fiat money in the
world to flow into the crypto economy so
we
you know we're very proud of that and i
think we've helped a lot of that money
flow in
now once people have money in crypto
they can choose to hold it in a variety
of ways and they can choose to hold it
in a self-custodial wallet which is more
decentralized they can choose to use
decentralized exchanges which
we we love and uniswap is not really i
don't think of them as like a direct
competitor to us we we basically have
integrated um unit swap into a number of
our products we we love d5 decentralized
exchanges all the whole thing
so
any coinbase wallet which is a
self-custodial wallet is more
decentralized and it allows people to
um hold their own crypto they don't have
to trust us can you explain what a
self-custodial wallet is what is the
wallet and what is the self-custodial
wallet yeah so it's confusing so um so a
custodial wallet means you're trusting
coinbase to store
your crypto the private keys themselves
and you know for some people in
institutions and everything just meeting
them where they are today that's nice
because it's simpler you know
um they're not afraid of losing their
crypto if they make some accident
accidental mistake or so you know a
custodial
um crypto products are important to help
get a bunch of people into the ecosystem
but
i'm very supportive of self-custodial
wallets and i think in some ways they
are the future because more and more
people are going to want to store their
own crypto not trust a third-party
institution do it and in some ways that
is much more authentic to the ethos of
crypto so
coinbase will help you convert the fiat
into crypto in a
frankly that's a more centralized thing
but once you have crypto you can then go
to the self custodial world store it
yourself in in a to get into the
technical details just for a second
it's basically saying um
you're going to store the keys on your
own device
and so um even if coinbase you know
gets some court order to seize it we
actually can't like from an architecture
point of view we can't do it um or you
know if coinbase gets hacked or
something we can't lose your funds like
now you the thing is you have to take
the responsibility because we're not
taking it so the individual person could
get hacked right and
there's a whole bunch of really cool
research happening to make self
custodial wallets
more resilient to accidental loss
hacks and just user error like
you know
they're i don't know how much you've
looked at like various cryptography
things but there's like basically um you
can have multiple key multi-sig
multiple signatures from different keys
on different devices where you need like
two of the three or three of the five
there's a whole um technology called
multi-party computation or threshold
signing signatures which is really cool
um but those are the things you would
run locally
like these are all security measures
like cryptography measures to protect
you
without a centralized component
right so like a simple example would be
let's say you had a two of three
key signature and
you know one key might be sort of
coinbase but that's not a quorum so we
couldn't unilaterally move your funds
but another key is on your device on
your phone let's say oh cool um so that
so in a normal situation you have a key
on your phone we have one
um but you and so two out of three now
just you know it can all get signed very
quickly for day-to-day use but let's say
you lose your phone or something
now there has to be a third key and
that's where you know you could store it
in a backup somewhere um like in google
drive or icloud you could trust a third
party that's not coinbase to also have
that one key and they can't do anything
unilaterally with that one key so that's
a simple example you can get you can get
way more complicated yeah that's an
awesome idea and so like yeah if your
funds get seized
coinbase can't can't do anything right
uh but you better not lose your phone
maybe in that case yeah
so yeah that's
but it provides a there is so even if
you lose your phone then there is a
recovery mechanism because you can get
the one key from coinbase the one from
your backup provider
and recover
a new one back on your phone i know yeah
but but what if coinbase is no longer
but because of government because of
what say it's in north korea
government says you're no longer like
coinbase is shut down in that country or
something like that right then you can
get it even if you have access to those
too right
so uh again
perhaps a silly question but isn't a
self-custodial wallet
a competitor as a notion
to coinbase
no i mean we so we offer
a self custodial wallet um we've built
one and it's like but doesn't it bleed
the like i guess i'm asking a sort of a
financial question
is uh like how does coinbase make money
on transactions so does this not does it
does not decrease the number or does not
significantly negatively affect
transactions or are you more focused on
growing the number of the pie of the
number of people that are using
cryptocurrency yeah like a traditional
financial service firm would probably
say
well we should be storing let's keep
more of the custody with us because
that's how we prove to the world that
we're valuable or whatever
i don't really believe that like i think
that actually we kind of want to
encourage our users to move to
self-custody over time for those who are
ready and willing
and that technology needs to mature i'm
not trying to like force anybody to do
it who doesn't want to do it but
to me that's like the future of how we
get billions of people using crypto but
doesn't that mean they can go somewhere
else
easier yeah that's sort of the point is
like we're all using the same protocol
so there's low switching costs which
keeps all the companies accountable
right like
if you
if you want to access the visa network
there's only one company in the world
you can go through to do that like visa
but if you want to access the bitcoin
network there's dozens or hundreds of
companies out there who can do that so
it's you know it's arguably you could
argue it's worse for us as a company but
i think it's better for it's what makes
bitcoin interesting and cryptocurrency
interesting is that nobody controls it
there is low switching cost for
customers it's better for customers and
that means that all the companies in the
space are going to be held to a high
standard because the minute you lose
someone's trust they're going to move
their bitcoin to some other service
and that's good for the world do you
think of coinbase as uh so there's these
ideas of layer one layer two layer three
technologies yeah do you think of
coinbase
as layer one layer two layer three now
that
that said there's so many
um
products that are under the coinbase
umbrella that's hard to answer that
question but what do you think
yeah do you acknowledge the existence of
layer three
so so you know usually when people are
using those terms layer one layer to
this so they're referring to like layer
one would be um the blockchain layer one
blockchain itself like like a bitcoin or
ethereum or something not like a a
centralized service like coinbase or
even our decentralized um self-custodial
wallet
so um
yeah i wouldn't consider us to be like a
layer one these are these are the
decentralized protocols that we're
integrating but we are coinbase itself
is not those yes but layer two is the
thing that was basically doing
transactions without the settlement
on the blockchain
and so you you get to have some of the
benefits of faster transactions without
um
the the security associated with the
blockchain and
layer three
is i suppose
sort of apps built on top of that
so you know uh at least i think talking
to michael saylor he considers coinbase
a layer three technology
interesting
okay i'm not really
particularly familiar with this kind of
distinctional there three and two i
don't see them as fundamentally
different
uh but
some of the okay i mean one way of
asking that
is there some layer two like of magic
happening in order to make transactions
associated with the blockchain happen
instant so that they're quick
so that coinbase on coinbase yeah
um is there some magic going on because
you're okay we should say how many
cryptocurrencies are currently on
coinbase so it's more than two
yeah
it's a lot more than two yeah so you
have to understand they have to
incorporate all these technologies yeah
so how do you make that magic
of sort of universal transactions happen
across all of these different
cryptocurrencies
there's our centralized products and
decentralized products right the
centralized products
um we are storing
that crypto for you and so if you're
moving from one of your accounts to
another account like
each one account to eth2 account or
um from my ether ethe coinbase
centralized account to your ether so we
can do that transaction off chain to
make it faster and it saves the customer
fees and it just confirms instantly but
it's not truly using the decentralized
blockchain right so you can also send to
any any bitcoin address or a theorem
address for instance and that is putting
the transaction on chain now our
decentralized products like coinbase
wallet the the self custodial wallet
every transaction is happening on chain
with that and so basically what it just
shows a little bit of the evolution of
coinbase and the blockchains themselves
like in the early days um these you know
the we these networks were not scalable
and so there were no l2 solutions for
instance
and so we had to do sort of these hacks
like moving the crypto off chain if you
were moving between your own accounts
and stuff like that otherwise the miner
fees would have just eaten us alive as a
company right and we yeah but now that
like
the blockchains are starting to scale
there's a whole bunch more work that
needs to be done on that and we're
getting l2 solutions so i think more and
more of the transactions are going on
chain whether it's l2 l1
and you know we shouldn't be like
ideally we shouldn't be doing that many
transactions um you know off chain but
just internal coinbase ledger or
something that's not really in the
spirit of crypto so when you say
unchained that includes like a lightning
net that includes layer
layer two technology that the blockchain
proposes yeah so you're when you yeah
okay so i guess i was asking how much
fun magic is happening off-chain within
coinbase and you're saying in the early
days you had to
but you try and do less and less
so look there's a bunch of like high
frequency traders that use the
centralized products and even just
regular retail people like they don't
want to pay the gas fees and stuff and
they're trying to it actually we we
um back at the envelope you know
calculated this out at one point
and just like
it would be completely infeasible for
like high frequency traders to put
everything on chain at this point that's
basically what dexes are doing and so
both are important i think more and more
is going to move decentralized over time
which is great and we're and we're
basically our decentralized exchanges
yeah by the way yeah yeah
um
so anyway we want to we want to
encourage more and more of it to move
decentralized over time but i don't the
centralized things aren't going away for
like a long time it's a decade from now
there's gonna be some
big institution or pension fund or
central bank that's like all right we
gotta hold crypto
let's set up the account in a
centralized way so that's that's fine
both both are important do you know the
number of cryptocurrencies currently on
coinbase do you know that number it's
over a hundred but it depends it depends
what jurisdiction you're in and you know
are you um
an institution versus retail it's like
there's so many different categories now
yeah
so what does it take to become
to to to become an asset to become a
cryptocurrency on coinbase to
add your technology to coinbase
okay well so we're trying to get away
from this idea of being listed on
coinbase as being seen as like an
endorsement or something because
i actually think it's very important
that we are not considered um
judge and jury about you know like
imagine in the early days of the
internet and you were like what's a good
web page and what's a bad web page like
you would have been totally wrong or
anytime
big tech companies try to make these um
review review boards of like you know
apple famously gets in trouble for this
a lot with their app store review
process right
and so
something that you think like a
committee of people somewhere thinks
looks silly may turn out to be the next
big thing right and so it's very
difficult so what do we do i mean we
basically have a test of legality right
we we check um
you know do we belie do we believe this
is a security if so it can't be listed
on coinbase and there's a very rigorous
process we go through for that um just
currently the way the laws are in the us
you can't you can't do that and we've
been we acquired a broker dealer license
from the sec we're trying to work with
them to get that operational and
hopefully someday we can trade real
crypto securities but today that's not
possible in the us at least
um then we look at sort of the cyber
security of the the crypto asset does it
do we think there's some flaw in the
smart contract or
you know a way that somebody could um
manipulate it without the customer's
permission
we look at some compliance pieces to it
as well like the
the actors behind it and like you know
they're any kind of criminal history
anything like that but if we believe it
meets our our
listing standards basically the this
test of um legality and everything for
for customer protection then we want to
list it because we want the market to at
that point decide and it's kind of like
um
it's kind of like amazon or something
like that where you know it a product
might have three stars or it might have
five stars but if it starts to get one
star consistently like it's probably
fraudulent or it's defective or
something like maybe amazon will remove
it but otherwise you want to let the
market decide what these things are
um
so that's generally how we do it and by
the way more and more of these
assets um i think especially like low
market cap assets are going to be traded
on dexes through coinbase it's not that
we
we don't need to list every asset on a
centralized exchange i think dexes are
really good for the long tail and then
it becomes an even
it's even more clear to people like this
is not some endorsement by a coinbase of
like
this assets good and this one's bad like
you know my belief is there's going to
be millions of these assets over time
and so
um
i hope it doesn't like make news every
time we add one in the future basically
yeah i wonder how you get there because
i even i look to coinbase
for for example you know people as you
could imagine
sort of tagged me on twitter or
something like that and all that like
you should interview
our sort of this the the founder of this
particular coin right yeah and i it's so
hard for me to know
what's ha first of all what's
interesting technology
what's uh
who's a scammer or not who's actually
legitimately representing an ambitious
new thing versus
a scam
and i you know there's very few sources
of uh
like verification signal
and unfortunately coinbase in part has
become
a little bit of that too and you're
trying to get away from that because
you're trying to get as many so let the
people decide so you're thinking of like
amazon star type system
where the people could rate
yeah so i think we'll actually probably
add like user ratings and reviews so um
and and we'll be very cautious about
like you know these are real people um
there's a bunch of stuff we have to do
from that already so i think wisdom of
the crowds is good in terms of getting
feedback on items but we also we're
gonna do our own review which i
mentioned earlier right which is like
okay it meets this minimum bar to be
listed on our site yeah um
i think yeah both are important how do
you know if if a coin is a scam or not
well you can you can see a few things so
you know i hate to use the word scam
because a lot of these these are
judgment calls you got a kind of a court
made me or a jury may land either way
but things that would be red flags to
look at would be
um you know is a bunch of the
asset owned by an insider or insiders um
with short vesting periods
um
you know are
does the background of the founders like
they may have criminal records or
they've perpetrated other frauds in the
past right
um there's a difference between
something which is
just a me too product it's like it
doesn't have anything interesting about
it and something that's an actual fraud
or outright scam and
um
you have to a lot of this data what's
cool about it is that it's now available
on chain you can look at like the
tokenomics behind it and see who owns
economics and are they yeah and are they
selling it you know
in like inappropriately or are they
pumping it on like youtube and twitter
and making promises about hey the value
of this thing may be a higher in the
future and like all those are just big
big no-nos that we would
um
you know we just don't want to go there
so
our whole thing is like we want we want
to enable innovation in this space but
not allow anybody to
curtail the advancement of this industry
by like doing some kind of fraudulent
thing or get rich quick thing so it's a
tricky industry because i'm trying to
figure out who to you know
uh what's interesting to to to to
understand to research yeah and uh it's
hard to know let me ask you about a
trick you want to add to a centralized
exchange which is privacy preserving
cryptocurrency so like monero yeah is
that is that technically difficult or is
that why
why is like monero for example forget
that specific one but like privacy
preserving
cryptocurrency blockchains uh why is
that ever possible to add
so that's that's a great question so the
answer is maybe
so um
here here's the here's the what the
reason why so
um because we're a regulated financial
service business we have various um
licenses to do that we are we are
regulated by various regulators part of
those licenses requires us to have a
quote reasonable um program to monitor
for
suspicious activity um
you know an aml program anti-money
laundering right and so if it if a coin
is 100 anonymous and we can't really do
blockchain analytics to track
um sorts of funds and where these things
might be going
it makes it harder to have a
um a reasonable program around that
that's defensible now there are privacy
preserving coins like zcash which have
something called a view key and a view
key is basically another key which
allows you to de-anonymize the
transactions in specific situations
where you want that so for instance um
you know we do support zcash and one of
the ways we got comfortable with that is
that
when you're buying it on coinbase um you
know you can basically have a view key
the the transactions are not anonymous
while you're buying it and we can see
where it goes afterwards and do our our
whole standard program
um now if it gets a few hops away down
the road i mean people could eventually
turn on privacy preserving aspects
so you know these are tough judgment
calls but at least in terms of our
interaction with the customer and
everything we feel comfortable at that
i think there's a broader point here
which is that i actually think privacy
coins are a good thing for the world and
we and they should be allowed and more
like you know
despite we've made this judgment call to
operate in a regulated and safe and
compliant way but
just taking my coinbase head off for a
minute i think the world would be a
better
place if there were more privacy coins
because it's kind of like the internet
when it first came online like there was
no https everything was http and there
was you know so people were afraid to
put their credit cards on the internet
and um your your messages could be
intercepted and all the stuff and now
the whole internet has basically moved
to https with a little lock icon in your
browser
which is better like and and financial
information is like the most important
information to keep private right
so there's times where let's say you're
running a charity or something and you
want to have total auditability
transparency for the whole world who
donated and where did the money go
that's great you want it to be public
but if it's like your personal money or
something like that you don't want to be
broadcasting that to the whole world and
in some ways that's what blockchains are
doing
you know pseudonymously because like but
it is a public ledger and so if you can
know who owns each address you can
basically de-anonymize it
i you know i think basically the people
should fight for um privacy and freedoms
of all kind but privacy of money is a
good thing so i would like to see more
of that in the future you chosen with
coinbase to
to uh to have a seat at the table with
the regulators yeah so what kind of
what kind of conversations
are there at that table what are the
regulations like
what is the level of understanding with
regulators
what are they worried about what are
they thinking about what are the
positive and what are the negative
regulations that you're facing
that you're educating struggling with
pushing back on supporting all that kind
of stuff yeah
oh man there's so many because we're i
mean we're live in
like
you know maybe 100 countries or more at
this point so the the conversations are
all over the map
um i'm trying to think what broad
strokes i could paint for you so i'd say
one trend that's that's positive is that
basically regulators around the world
are con are more and more as over the
last five years i would say
it's more and more common to find a
regulator today
asking
how can we preserve the innovation
potential of this technology
while keeping the bad actors out than it
was five years ago where they were
saying this is all bad activity how do
we prevent it
and so
um maybe this is when you say more and
more
what fraction
[Laughter]
i'll give you like a u.s specific
example although we operate in many
countries so when i go to dc now i would
say
you know 50 60 of the people who i meet
with are basically
you know they're in the camp of crypto
has a lot of potential we should
regulate it to make sure the bad people
don't do something bad with it but this
is here to stay and it has a lot of
upside we should basically
um create thoughtful regulation and
celebrate it and actually encourage this
innovation to happen in the u.s that's
a huge change from just three years ago
where it was probably 30 of people
saying that now it's like 60. it's like
almost double it's getting harder to
find like true cryptoskeptics in dc
um i'd say that you know
maybe maybe only like 20 or 30 of people
are like willing to say something
negative like they actually think it's
net negative it's like it's really hard
to defend that position at this point
because
almost like one in five americans have
used or tried crypto at this point so
you're kind of condemning 20 of your
fellow citizens if you say that at this
point
um
you know especially with nfts and all
these things like a huge segment of
people who don't even care about
investing or whatever came into the
space so
and then basically that's that same
conversation is happening um but
you know delayed by a few years in in
like india and europe and in in some
asian countries and
um
some countries have really embraced
crypto and they're like trying to really
they're they're ahead of where the us is
because they're trying to actually uh
attract the best startups and
entrepreneurs like you know like dubai
and uk and australia and all kind of
pushing good regulation
um el salvador actually i guess adopted
it as like bitcoin as a legal tender
there was another country central
african republic i think that supposedly
did that as well
but
you know there's countries like china
that are more autocratic that are saying
hey this is a threat to our power and
like we're going to try to really
curtail it so what kind of regulations
are there that you feel the most
that are limiting or that are empowering
like is there specific examples
yeah okay so um
i mean basically i think the securities
laws in the u.s need to be clarified
about
um
what
there's crypto is many different things
that's what people don't realize so like
some crypto like bitcoin ethereum and
many others are probably more like
commodities
um they're not controlled by any one
person you know like
anyway there's people who want to raise
money for a company that sounds more
like a security that should be regulated
by the sec commodities are regulated by
the cftc
then there's some cryptocurrencies which
are more like uh currencies like stable
coins and central bank digital
currencies and
those are probably you know should be
regulated by the treasury or someone
like that and then there's a whole
another category of cryptocurrencies
which are none of those things they're
they're nfts like artwork or their
metaverse items or decentralized
identity and voting and
so
i i think that there's a very um
unhelpful
point of view out there by some folks
which is
hey this is all most of this is like bad
activity we need to shut it down so
we're just going to pursue enforcement
actions or something like that most
people in dc don't feel that way anymore
and i think the people of the us don't
feel that way anymore
because a lot of them are using this
stuff and their their general view is
there's a lot of upside potential here
we can all agree let's get rid of the
fraud and the scams we all want to get
rid of that
so let's create a relatively simple test
which says
you know if it's like
nobody controls more than 20 of it or
some threshold it probably is more like
a commodity if someone's raising money
for they're selling this thing for a
business then it's probably a security
and then you know if it's more like a
medium of exchange it's a currency and
if it's none of those things maybe it's
artwork or whatever
a legal test like that would help
clarify who which regulator is
regulating what
and then um you know we also want to
have probably like a sandbox for
innovation where if you're a startup and
you're doing less than i don't know some
number
um
less than some amount of payment volume
or customer funds you're storing it's
like just let those things get off the
ground without
a soul-crushing amount of legal bills
you know and uncertainty so if the u.s
can get there that would be great i
think a bunch of other countries now are
rushing around the world to sort of
create that regulation that it does
attract innovation
and so um in the nash international
bodies like imf and g20 and stuff
they're they're starting to look at
proposed regulation
i hope that coinbase and a bunch of
other crypto companies can help in that
conversation too we have a whole policy
effort i think actually crypto policy
efforts are like probably one of the
biggest things in dc right now so
um
it moves it moves slow at the speed of
government but um
yeah and in the meantime we're just
trying to help more and more people use
crypto because ultimately that's what in
the democracies that's what they care
about like they'll do what the people of
the country want so you want governments
to start understanding uh differences
between in the crypto space commodities
securities currencies nfts i still don't
understand
what is supposed to make sense of nfts
what is nfts exactly from a perspective
of a regulator
yeah so um
is it the other categories is that yeah
you know most nfts you could think of as
like artwork although it's it's who
knows where it's going to go it could be
you mentioned metaverse right you
mentioned some kind of unique identity
of a thing
yeah like i mean there's everything
yeah right nfts
i actually i bought this nft that's like
um
it's like citizenship in this like city
dao in wyoming like i've never been
there but um it's almost like a
like a as like a badge or at a station
like to get access to this location
um
there's like people doing like like
tickets to events like you know they're
called uh co-ops like um
proof of attendance and things like that
so
it'll be very interesting to see where
nfts go over time it could get
that's and that's the danger you don't
want to try to like define the
regulation if you don't even know where
this thing's going to go so and so your
efforts on the policy arm is is
education
yeah education advocacy
we're just trying to be like a helpful
educational resource essentially and
then if they give us feedback and like
hey
don't do this or don't or do this like
we're more than happy to do anything
that's requested
we generally go get licenses and we've
just tried to do the right thing in the
absence of clarity because
it's if it's not clear what what the law
says then you should just basically do
good things that you think may be
required in the future to show good
faith effort towards the right thing
and uh
that's part of like innovating in a
regulated field which is you know whole
topic in itself so if you are
at the table i mean
this is less the case in the united
states but can government agencies seize
a person cryptocurrency by forcing
coinbase
to to hand it over
so when you're centralized you they have
a phone number to call
okay so this is a complicated topic
um like if you really want to be sure
that um this is why people want to store
their own crypto right like with
self-custodial wallets like with
coinbase wallet and bracing
decentralization they want to avoid that
now in the u.s there is rule of law
right so we have reasonable protections
in place around um like search and
seizure and things like that
um you know coinbase does we publish
transparency reports on this we get
subpoenas court orders things like that
from various um countries around the
world and um
there are situations where we have been
ordered to freeze accounts things like
that um
you know we have to follow the law is
there's no another way to put it we're a
regulated financial service business and
so if the money is used to break as part
of breaking the law that's what that uh
in a particular
jurisdiction in particular
right and then the other thing sometimes
you we will actually get court orders or
subpoenas that are overly broad we've
seen so they need to follow
due process right and so we've seen um
some in the past that were like well we
need you to freeze this huge number of
accounts and it's like well
we'll actually have gone to court and
like pushed back on some of these and
said like what is your the probable
cause and is that has the threshold been
met and like we've won some of those
cases on behalf of our customers so
yeah it's it's actually really
it's kind of unfortunate and frustrating
as a you know as a large business you
spend a lot of resources basically
interacting with
inbound requests by all kinds of lawyers
and people and
requesting things and some of them are
silly and ridiculous and you have to
push back and say no and so
it's kind of a tax on every company at a
certain size which ultimately gets
passed on to the the customer in higher
fees so
you have to employ armies of lawyers to
deal with this stuff can you educate me
on something how much innovation
is there in the legal space
so for lawyers working with coinbase
because it's such a new
cutting-edge thing
so you're
if there's a lot of gray area you're
supposed to be operating
under like how hard is is it being a
lawyer at coinbase
like uh how much precedence is there i
guess is what i'm asking i mean just
like you said three years
it's kind of a new space yeah well it's
probably very hard to be alert coinbase
and very fun because
you know whenever you're in a new field
that's growing fast there isn't a lot of
um
case law and just precedent set so
that's also an opportunity for you to go
create that stuff and that's what a lot
of legal careers are made out of is like
take a complex situation where you have
to balance difficult things like how do
we prevent bad activity but still enable
an innovation that's a hard question
and there's you can go draft legislation
and circulate it to policy policymakers
or
come up with these policies and
you know how do you operate a business
in an environment where
the law is just unclear right it's like
try to do the right thing
um but like
you know strike the right balance so
yeah a lot of our lawyers have to come
up with that very creative stuff you
mentioned one of the things you're
focused on is expanding the number of
people maybe a billion people
on coinbase or using cryptocurrency
where are we at now how did we get to a
billion
as of q4 last year we had 89 million
verified accounts on coinbase but in any
given
uh quarter only you know maybe
like 10 or a little more million of
those are like really active so
um and then if you look at globally i
think some of the estimates i've seen is
maybe there's like 200 million people or
something like that who have ever used
or tried crypto
so
we're along you know
ways from a billion but it's not like
that far off
um how do you get there
yeah
so a few things one is the blockchains
have got to become way more scalable
um it's kind of like we're all running
dial-up modems and we need broadband and
so it's just like
too expensive too slow to do all these
transactions and i think
if we just get l2s working and
scalability you know we'll see another
order of magnitude kind of come out just
from that
um i think the second one be more clear
regulation that would help a lot um
i do talk to you know pension funds and
um
you know various asset managers
sovereign wealth funds and stuff and
a lot of them tell me we've we've got
one percent of our portfolio in crypto
today
but
we really would rather have like 20 in
there but what we're waiting for is
more clear regulation um coming out and
saying that clear test that i was saying
these assets are commodities regulated
by so if you see these are my sec these
are about treasury whatever
so that would be a big unlock
do transactions so one of the things
that you mentioned uh payments sorry
yeah well does that unlock a lot of
users
yeah it does i mean remittance is like a
huge thing people sending money home to
their families in other countries where
the fees are super high so yeah if we
get blockchains to be more scalable and
there's more global adoption like i
think we'll see
remittance quarters um move over to
crypto a lot
there's also just um the other thing
that's driving a lot of crypto adoption
is basically
the creation of more and more
third-party apps so or adapts they're
sometimes called decentralized apps so a
lot of startups now um
you know how like you used to use in the
early 2000s they called them.com
startups but now you don't need to
say.com because everybody's using the
internet and so now there's like
hundreds or thousands of these crypto
startups
but i think in the future you won't need
to call them crypto startups because
they'll just be called startups because
everyone's using the internet and crypto
and whatever so
anyway the the the use cases the utility
of crypto is is getting better and
better with like all these third-party
apps getting funded and created and do
you think there's gonna be a killer
or a set of killer daps
like a thing where nobody can live
without are we still waiting for that
there's gonna be a bunch of them it's
just like it's like the internet like
what were the killer web companies you
know like uber and wikipedia and airbnb
and google and like
so
there's going to be some big winners but
there'll be thousands of this is
basically the new
it's like what happened with the dot-com
startups in the early 2000s it's like a
lot of the best entrepreneurs are
building crypto startups now so
um tons of venture money flowing into
the space a lot of smart young people so
do you think bitcoin or some other
cryptocurrency will become the reserve
currency of the world at some point
so this is kind of a controversial idea
but i actually think yes um
i do think bitcoin could end up becoming
a reserve currency of the world there's
so you know i've been reading ray dalio
recently um
with his new book like the changing
world order and i i thought it was a
really well researched book um
he talks in there he looks back at
history right he looks at like empires
and
um you know going back to various
chinese empires the dutch and ottomans
and everybody and
how did they rise and they they were
able to have the reserve currency as
they as they rose and what produced that
like it came from you know good
education and innovation and better
trade and anyway
so
the u.s by some measures is kind of
looks like it's maybe it's had a really
good run and it's coming down a little
bit and china is kind of kind of coming
up who knows how that'll play out by the
way like the world is very complicated
it could that could switch
um
but i guess
if the u.s dollar is going to be seeing
more inflation in the future
the chinese yuan is not like
necessarily better right i mean
they have a ton of debt as well and um
you know it's not like
you could really that that the yuan
could be inflated as well right i
probably will be and so i do think that
there's this group of people today which
probably most traditional um
i don't know like the people
who run big banks and like governments
and stuff that they're not this is not
really on their radar today but i think
there's there's a basically a group of
younger people in that kind of
you know 25 35 year old range who are
tech savvy
they're starting to think of crypto as
like the primary thing
in their financial life it's like
i basically hold my wealth in crypto and
i use
dollars or euros or whatever if i if i
happen to need something i convert it to
that last minute it's like if i if i go
home if i'm traveling i might convert
some local currency in the moment but
that's not where i hold my most of my
wealth
so this segment of the population is not
like
massive yet from a gdp point of view but
um i think it's a leading indicator of
where things could be going and this is
actually good for the world it's kind of
like
especially if china does continue to
rise and it has a more authoritarian
view it'll be kind of this very
centralized east versus a decentralized
west
um where people are in the west in the
free world really kind of embracing
um crypto and a more open fair free
global
financial system which i think will
be enormously beneficial for humanity
and i do think basically bitcoin is the
reserve currency the gold standard of
the crypto economy
um
so that's pretty crazy yeah the gold
standard i mean it's also
like with ray dalio
um
i feel like china will drive a lot of
this
either in response or directly i mean um
i think the ruble i'm not paying as
close attention to the financial systems
but
i think they're trying to tie it to gold
once again so that's an interesting
maybe it'll be one of the more
authoritarian regime that will switch to
bitcoin standard first
and then
um it's the the west that will
out of that pressure will catch up
versus uh versus the other way around
it's
it's it's fascinating to think of what
is the
the forcing function
what kind of perturbation is required to
switch to change anything honestly about
the financial system but
it could be
um
as you're saying just waiting for the
people that are young now that are
embracing crypto to
enter the positions of power
essentially
but i hope that's not the case because
that's uh
if for any innovation we have to wait
um sorry to say for the older folk to to
pass away yeah
that's not an efficient way to uh to
make change yeah
that is that's a super interesting topic
of how
people's minds become less plastic as
they age yeah
i guess it's a feature
it's called wisdom but then we also need
the wild ones to explore exploration
versus exploitation
you wrote a blog post that's really
interesting in september 2020 titled
coinbase is a mission-focused company
like what we're talking about
so one interesting thing you said in
that blog post is that
we're not going to be distracted by
sort of activism within the company
that's not related to the mission of the
company
now that's a rare thing for a company to
state for companies here at the state
especially in this climate
um
can you
first of all describe in a little more
detail what you meant
uh did you receive blow back for this i
definitely received some blow back but
yeah i'll describe what i meant and um
if you want to talk about how it came to
that too we can talk about that but
what i meant is that um
there's a lot of companies right now
including tech companies but not
exclusively where
um
you know i think like great companies
they have an important mission they're
trying to do something really good for
the world
and
unfortunately they're getting a little
distracted from that at times because of
employee activism that is causing the
company to
basically jump into whatever the current
thing is and try to
help is like the positive interpretation
you know the negative interpretation
would be to virtue signal
and
my view is that this is actually kind of
destructive to um this is largely an
american company phenomenon by the way i
i i do worry that this is making america
less competitive um even though i think
of myself as kind of internationally
minded but i you know i'm a u.s citizen
and have a lot my whole life here so
um
when we put out this statement we had
employees that were not in the u.s who
were confused by it they were like
why did brian need to say that you're
just saying you're going to work focus
on work at work
that's what we were doing already yeah
you know and there was certain pockets
of the us certain cities you know in
particular where we had employees that
um a very peculiar cultural
phenomenon had evolved where
i think people really wanted the company
they worked at to be
you know uh
almost acting like the government or
something and like trying to solve the
hardest societal issues and and how at
least have an opinion on it if not
contribute to the solution on almost
everything
um
and for me
i kind of uh
you know i was it was a very
uncomfortable situation for me as a ceo
i'd never quite been in this situation
where
most the time when employees in the past
were kind of asking me questions
um they would be asking about like you
know how do we make this product better
like what do we do with this competitor
what about this regulator
and it got to a place around that time
where um
most of the questions we were receiving
were i think even about things not
related to the company they were about
broader societal issues like brian
what's your stance on xyz controversial
thing
and you know it was
i often like didn't have an opinion on
these really hard questions right and um
i didn't really i felt like it was
distracting the company people
internally were getting into fights a
lot too like
disagreeing with each other there were
there was a thing where like the social
slack internally was turning into social
media almost with people putting in
flame wars
so and this culminated by the way with
um
a walkout that happened in the company
we we received like some demands from
employees groups about various things
and there was like basically an
antagonistic thing with management and
employ and i was like we're all on the
same team here
if you want to be antagonistic let's do
it with somebody else outside the
company you know that we're trying to
improve the world on in that dimension
so
yeah eventually i was like okay the
company is not aligned on this
i just don't feel i don't like the job
as ceo frankly like if if the job is to
come in here every day and like have to
squirm in front of like these the most
difficult societal questions
um i don't think i want to do that job
so like either they're gonna have to go
or i'm gonna have to go
and i founded this company and i really
believe in the mission so they're gonna
have to go and
what i realized was that um so i
basically i made an exit package
available to anybody who wasn't on board
with this direction five percent of
employees took it i got the company
realigned towards this this mission
we're all here to do work by the way
people can they can go do anything like
political or social activism outside of
work it's totally fine like we all
everybody has stuff like that
um in their personal life but while at
work we can also disagree at work by the
way on the work you know this is not
like a no disagreement culture like we
should let's try to get the truth
um but don't bring stuff into work
that's just going to create division
make the workplace a refuge from
division about all these crazy things
and like we're all aligned here to work
on the mission let's do that yeah that
was really
really
really refreshing to hear
so this is me speaking but there's a
sense when companies
take on these issues publicly from a ceo
position or anywhere else
that it does seem to optimize
for virtue signaling versus solving a
particular problem
because to solve a particular problem
you really have to
really put in a huge you have to hire a
huge number you basically have to create
a company within a company to take on a
particular thing right uh but if you
allow yourself to internally care
about a particular issue you're
basically pacifying some number of
employee like making sure slack doesn't
get out of hand and then you're doing
this kind of from my perspective
especially on issues that care about
fake virtue signaling basically trying
to understand what will make me look the
best what would make the company look
the best in this particular aspect and
it just seems very shallow and it's
optimizing for the wrong thing not for
the solving of the problems yeah but for
the
making yourself look like the good guy
and trying to then leverage that to say
i'm the good guy in all situations and
it's just it's it's the wrong thing and
perhaps from your perspective as a ceo
for as a leader it's also creating
division unnecessary division within
people like they get yeah there's
something to bother us we get
extremely
argumentative about certain topics they
really bring out the emotion yeah
and i think that probably as you were
saying that emotion
is even probably okay maybe productive
when that emotion has to do with the
mission of the company yeah like you
really care about
those disagreements versus like
something that has nothing to
nothing to do with a particular with uh
with increasing economic freedom
uh using crypto
yeah it's fascinating
but it was so refreshing because it's
rare
why do you think that's a rare
so you the city you're mentioning
i mean there's a bunch of cities uh but
you know san francisco
is one such city when one when that
culture
and
it's sad because san francisco is also
the bay area is also the hub
historically of some of the greatest
innovation in human history yeah so that
there's that tension how did that
culture emerge there
where like the innovation was done by
people that are very mission driven you
get a bunch of smart people together to
solve a difficult problem
they get maybe sometimes too much
blinders on but they try to balance that
and because it requires that focus to
solve an actual problem and yet that's
also the place where this culture
emerged it's a fascinating human
dynamic i don't know somebody will one
day tell the history of of uh silicon
valley
not just the innovation but the social
dynamics that occurred there anyway why
do you think that's so rare
well because people don't want to get
attacked it's like super you don't want
to get canceled right it's super unpro
un uh comfortable you know nobody wants
to be called a racist or whatever
whatever you know people want to say on
twitter so um get attacked
yeah yeah i definitely got attacked i
mean and i knew i knew it would be
controversial the only reason i did it
frankly was that
um
i was kind of at my wit's end i was like
well like i said earlier like the job
the ceo job sucks like either i don't
want to do it or they have to go and i'm
going to make the company into something
that i want and
you know
i spent um i'd spent eight or nine years
of my life at that point kind of
building this thing i was like well i
could go start another company but it
takes a long time to get momentum with
these things and
you know coinbase is a very rare thing
that happened in the world i feel very
passionate about it so
um yeah i'm not going to go like i need
to make this the company that i want to
work at and what was really interesting
was that there was such a huge
outpouring of support
so i knew that it would be controversial
and i would get attacked and predictably
you know there was some um
some journalists and you know new york
times and all these people who kind of
like went and started writing hit pieces
on on the company after shortly
thereafter and they basically just call
people who've left the company and like
you know can get quotes on whatever they
want and then they'll write a story so
mainstream media i lost a lot of trust
in mainstream media frankly after that
and of course it's kind of become
obvious since then that um most
mainstream media is like hyper
politicized at this point it's basically
either super left or super right and
it's not really
that focused on
um
truth so that's that's kind of
unfortunate because i think journalism
is actually like really important in
society so that that whole thing got
eroded in the u.s luckily there's sort
of new media people like you um and a
whole bunch of people did that blog post
help that statement the the 95 people
that remained
is this still something you struggle
with because there it's also a culture
of the broader tech space
okay so that was an interesting thing
which was that so the 95 percent of
people stayed i got a huge outpouring of
support from people
who said
thank god you finally spoke up and said
something because
frankly
it was making not a very fun place to
work either
and i realized that there is
i think there was a i think is it the
steam to lab has this blog post about
the tyranny of the
the one percent or something like that
but there's basically a relatively small
group one five percent or something like
that that is
really
upset about something it's not the
majority of the company it's like five
percent there's another 15 or something
that are sympathetic to the cause
they're they're actually somewhat
suggestible they will go along with
whatever because it sounds reasonable
you know these are like real issues
they're talking about it's not not to
say that it's not real
and they'll kind of get swept up in it
but there's an 80 of the company that
basically
doesn't agree or just wants to get their
work done without all this drama
and or distraction and
they're afraid to speak up because if
they speak up they're afraid of being
again called a racist like fired you
know ostracized amongst their peers and
so
it did require um
it to get to a bad enough place for me
to finally say you know what i just i
feel like i have to do this
live through the short-term attacks of
the press which ultimately was very
freeing for me because now i don't
really care
and now i can actually just build the
company that i want to build without
like caring
about that so
and then what was cool was a lot of
really great people reached out to the
coinbase too after that and were like
i you know i'm an early engineer at
google or wherever and like
this culture has gotten kind of messed
up and like i want to work at a company
that's willing to stand for that and so
we've gotten a lot of good people come
over basically what i realized and by
the way are diversity numbers and all
that stuff like people told me when i
was drafting this post they're like
don't post this you're like people
underrepresented groups will never want
to work at this company again and i was
like i don't think that's true like i
talked to like our erg groups and
they're not telling me they care about
this stuff that much they're telling me
they just want to like be respected at
work and do good work and contribute so
my gut was telling me that that advice
was wrong and like i can tell you a year
a year after doing it like our diversity
numbers are basically either the same or
better in every category so that turned
out to be false
um
look i i hate to be like like i'm you
know polarizing on in either dimension
here like i just want to get good work
done and build good stuff with
technology so
you know um
i think companies should just have like
reasonable policies like you want to get
rid of bias and hiring you want to
attract great people from all
different backgrounds like you know we
have pledge one percent we put one
percent of the company equity into a
foundation like i hope we're able to do
good stuff with that that's
you know give back in some way but like
the main
the main message i guess for me is like
the core the core mission the core work
that we're doing on economic freedom and
just all of our products are that is
like the main value that we're
contributing in the world like let's
just do that more and hopefully we can
get from
89 million verified users to a billion
or whatever
and then um
i just think that's how we'll have the
biggest impact it's tempting though it's
so interesting how companies get tempted
to to help
yeah it's like and you step in and it's
almost like a drug and then you can't
you forget i mean like all of us in life
doesn't have to be companies you get
distracted
yeah and maintaining focus like you're
absolutely right the way for coinbase to
add value to the world is just to
maximize the mission
that it's on not not other not other
stuff and when you get wealthier more
successful there's becomes more and more
tempting
to just help out in some other shallow
ways and
it's fascinating and you just kind of
brought that to light so it was very
refreshing and it shouldn't be
controversial to sort of
focus on just getting stuff done well
let me ask you i mean do you think that
this it's all these things tie together
there's like a general trend of like
more censorship you know there's like
more cancel culture um
there's uh
some of these like freedom values are
kind of you know
even like freezing people's accounts
like the trucker thing that happened and
it seems like there's a general trend of
um
more authoritarian
you know uh policies there
but
do you think that do you feel like the
tide is turning on that like there's
counter examples to it we've seen
recently yeah i think it's uh the last
gasp of old way of doing things and so
there's desperation and so on because
to be fair
it's kind of the internet which is where
is the source of a lot of this where
people have a voice is making the power
centers of the world really nervous and
so that's where that's coming from i
think and and the internet is tricky
it's weird it's full of bots yeah it's
full of like misinformation of all kinds
yeah full of large groups with
conspiracy theories and so on uh and i
mean misinformation broadly people are
misusing the word misinformation they're
just
governments are just labeling random
things with misinformation just to
censor them
but
i just think it's just like a new
world where the internet is really
finally taking hold where there's
billions of devices and everybody has a
voice it's it's almost
uh basically governments
and powerful people
are slightly losing hold of power and
they're starting to freak out a little
bit
that's it and so and then once you have
young people that are coming up now
gain power i think will will rebalance
everything and and then there's yeah
like you said promising signs
um
that it's obvious that the majority of
people
want freedom and that means a lot of
things that means economic freedom that
means freedom to have a voice
um freedom to move around freedom to act
in the way they you know without without
reasonable sort of
um
limitations by people that don't have
their best interests and
i i gain more hope from just regular
people that are
uh fighting
and like demanding
the
being able to have freedom of speech
or more specifically sort of resisting
crude overreach of government in the
acts of censorship
at least in the united states
uh and hopefully that percolates out to
the rest of the world that's struggling
on a much more basic level where people
are being put in prison for the worst
they say not just banned from twitter
right could be worse
what are some
lessons
from your failures and your successes
about what it takes to run a company i
think
one of the things that i've learned
about leadership is that
you know i never really thought of
myself as a very natural leader to be
honest i don't think i was a natural
leader
but so i always envisioned you know good
leaders as like these military generals
like they seem so like confident and
they're just like bark orders you know
like charge that hill and do this and
i was i was actually like more
introverted and kind of um
i wasn't really confident in the way i
communicated and
you know and so
what i realized is that there's lots of
different kinds of leaders you can be
any kind of ceo you want right i was
kind of more like a product technical
focus ceo and i preferred to sort of
hear everyone's opinion
and i wasn't just gonna like render a
decision in the room in some like kind
of heated moment and like piss off half
the people i would be like all right i'm
gonna go think about it and i'll send
you my decision later today or tomorrow
or whatever and so i i would i found
ways to kind of make it work for me
where i could basically
i always tried to avoid like um
you know when people getting like super
emotional about something and like i
think they're they're thinking their
judgment goes down right and it's like
never make a decision when you're angry
right and so
if i would always sort of try to get a
sense of are these people like trying to
be right or are they trying to seek the
truth you know and you you can do these
little tricks like you know okay you
argue that person's position and you
argue the other one and like
see if you can genuinely represent it
now i know you're listening and you know
these kind of things
um but i guess sorry getting back to
your question about leadership i think
i basically just kept doing things that
were a little outside my comfort zone
and then my comfort zone kept getting
bigger and bigger you know yeah and so
that's i think that's how you build
confidence
is
you you do the thing that's scary and
it's like a little outside and like when
i first started coinbase i had never
managed anybody i would have i would
have never i would have been scared to
death to have put out like a very
controversial opinion like that and sort
of
all right
five percent of people go you know we
didn't know what percent was gonna be by
the way it could have been one percent
it could have been fifty percent like
but we went into it scary because i it
was a scary thing i was like i don't
know i think this is right i'm just
gonna do it
so if you do if you do enough scary
things like you'll build the confidence
and i feel like i'm still on that
journey every every year or two at
coinbase there's some big thing that
comes out is like oh my god like i
didn't sleep well for a week and like
this is the next level right
um but that's how you that's how you
learn and grow so you're still going up
that mountain through the fog one step
at a time yeah uh can i just quickly ask
you about a couple of other efforts that
are super interesting that you're
involved with so first of all
a little bit more old school fascinating
effort of research hub
um
so what what what's that about the
github for open science
yeah okay so basically i've had a chance
to try to help a couple other companies
get off the ground too because i want to
see various efforts out there um succeed
and
um one of them i've always thought about
like why is scientific research
not more like open source software or
why couldn't it be much faster right and
there's
you've probably have seen this like in
an academic setting right but
there's all kinds of things that feel
very antiquated to me about scientific
research everything from
the funding process and grants to how
peer review works to how you submit the
journals all the costs associated with
journals
you know that the people you'd think
like you'd get paid for this or
something and it would then be available
to all the taxpayers for free but no
they're like they're all paywalled and
there's like these big companies that
have sort of
in my view kind of held back um
innovation here
so and
the preprint servers like bioarchive and
archive.org have really helped this but
those websites are they look like
they're kind of from like 15 years ago
or something yeah it's like craigslist
yeah
so anyway i one of the things i
once once coinbase went public last year
i had a little bit of liquidity and i
was like all right let me fund a small
team let's see if we can
if they can like go off and make
something better here so we have a we
have a prototype out there uh it's at
researchhub.com people can check it out
and it's basically um
you know the first version is kind of
like reddit for science there's like
various hubs which are like journals um
you but you know you can publish papers
there you can use an electronic lab
notebook to sort of have a modern day
paper which is not just a pdf that's
static but it's a living document
ideally in the future you know you can
get comments and feedback from people on
there you can update it over time we
want people to be able to share the code
and the data sets associated with their
paper research paper is not just
a pdf
in the future we want to make it even
where like you know people can um
get funding for science through through
that site and even license out
innovations that they've made because
the other thing i've noticed in life is
that there's kind of like there's a
bunch of people working on science and
there's a bunch of people building
companies and they very very rarely
intersect but when they do you get the
best things like like spacex and
genentech and even google and like even
coinbase was based on a research paper
the bitcoin white paper
and so most business people are like
creating companies that don't have any
scientific innovation they're just like
marketing based on you know whatever and
then a lot of scientists are making
things which never actually benefit
humanity because they're not
commercialized and turned into products
and so
if we can somehow create a translation
layer between those two groups and help
them
you know help align the market forces
align scientific research to market
forces so that they're more incentivized
like if you if you discover crispr or
something like that like you should be a
billionaire you know and like all the
downstream implications of that
not going through some antiquated tech
transfer office or whatever and if you
and if you're an entrepreneur you should
be looking to commercialize the latest
scientific innovations and so that's
kind of like the long-term vision for
that site um i think it's just an early
step today but we've got like a really
passionate community on there that are
jumping into like you know computer
science or longevity or
um
various bio hubs or whatever and like
beginning to source the best innovations
but also discuss them and prove them and
publish through the site so i have a
question about incentives but first let
me say for people listening who are
outside of academia might not be
familiar with an absurd situation so
there's journals like you mentioned
and
scientists publishing those journals
and
the journals provide very little value
except
matching you with reviewers that are
unpaid
and so
uh
in the digital world they're providing
basically almost no value except hosting
your paper
and they put up a paywall and charge
people
to access that and that charge is not
like even netflix fees you're talking
about a lot of money
so they're basically
blocking your research that should be
wide open
uh from the world and creating a paywall
it's a fascinating like scam that's
actually holding back
i don't it's it's a shitty scam because
you're not making that much money
i feel like a definition of a scam you
should at least be making money that's
like significant amount of money you're
basically making shitty money and
holding back all of human knowledge okay
so that put aside and people get a
little confused because the journals
aren't the ones paying the scientists
people think like the journals are
somehow funding the scientists
therefore
they have the right to put up a paywall
no no the funding is coming from
elsewhere journals yeah are the middle
man that nobody asked for especially in
the digital world anyway
that said there is uh
interesting kind of incentives for
scientists which is prestige and so on
so
there's a
thing with journals if there's if
there's a prestigious journal
and you uh pass the review process you
get into that journal
or a prestigious conference in computer
science then that's seen as a good thing
in your resume
and not just your resume within your
community that's a respected thing is
there some way to achieve that same kind
of incentive in an open um
in the open setting of research hub so
like where i could say i got
x y and z like look i'm impressive
because this happened on research hub i
think you're right like the whole um
academia like progress track is about
like where you got published and how
many citations and it's kind of like a
false economy
of um
reputation because like there's not real
money backing it and so i think we've
thought about this a little bit um
and i think the research hub team has an
opportunity to do something here that
basically says like okay i had the top
paper for 2022 in
um you know biology on in here and you
basically publish a list a leaderboards
of these like top you know for the month
the the year um in all these different
categories then actually you know we
should probably give out grants and
awards um in in addition to that fund
those people almost like fellows or
even give out like you know like the
nobel prize
there should be like a research hub
prize or something and like ship people
maybe maybe even ship like a print
version of a journal that is the top
papers in each category in each month or
whatever and like people want to put
that in their wall in in the lab and
like so i do think we need to sort of
change i don't know like the traditional
folks in academia or science would
probably think this is like crazy a
crazy idea but i think we need to change
the culture to
not celebrate getting published in
paywall journals
almost like friends don't let friends
publish in
like
paywall journals like because that's
it's just not helping humanity so like
you know it should be more prestigious
to publish
in an open science way
and get the top spot that should be
celebrated above being published in
whatever i don't even want to name one
of them you know well there's currently
it's the culture has already shifted to
where almost everybody publishes an
archive and by archive and so on yeah
but
so that the culture is there on that
that scene friends don't let friends not
publish open but then the prestige thing
is missing which is like anyone can
publish an archive yeah so how do you
know it's actually a strong paper now
funny enough even with the crappy
systems we have now
word of mouth is powerful like you have
a like citation system is pretty
powerful so like you say okay this is a
strong paper we don't need reviewers our
human eyes are the reviewers like that
the community are the reviewers so it's
already it's like that part is there but
it it would be nice to have like
uh
you know nature level like this is
respect this is a respectful
accomplishment yeah and something like a
leaderboard but a stable kind of system
yeah and i should mention so there's a
crypto angle to this too which is um so
research hub has a coin associated with
research coin and it's basically if if
people you know upvote your paper or
like
support it you'll accumulate more
research coin which is basically like
rep or like a reward token um and so
that is a way to um
i guess measure the the community's
collective view of that paper
a form of peer review um and it can even
be weighted by like the reputation of
the people voting on it and that sort of
thing over time
um
yeah i think the last thing i'll just
say is that so i think from from a rep
like a prestige point of view
it won't start off that way it'll
probably start off like being a little
more quirky like you know like remember
when youtube first started it was like
people posting weird cat videos and
stuff and but now like you know if you
have a million subscribers on youtube
that's probably better than getting like
a tv show on nbc or whoever the
traditional gatekeeper was
so my hope it might take 10 years 20
years whatever but i'm hoping that
this can sort of be the new prestigious
way that that young people publish in
science and it'll become to be viewed as
more prestigious the the journals
nutritional journals will be viewed as
old-fashioned well
it's definitely a
system that could do a lot better and
there's a lot of incredible brilliant
people doing science
they deserve better the better platforms
yeah uh so another thing you're taking
on and helping out with is this new
limit which is looking at longevity yeah
what's what's the idea there
yeah okay so as you can see i'm excited
about science like i think you know
science is sort of the
basically if you get scientific
innovation then you get um better
products and you get better economic
growth and then you get
all kinds of like surplus in society
that can go to arts and philosophy and
like all kinds of stuff but
um with new limits so yeah i kind of got
i started hosting some dinners with
scientists um
last year and i was
learning about all kinds of the latest
stuff happening in bio and there's a lot
of really cool stuff happening with like
car t cells and crispr and all these
things and um anyway one of the
topics that i started to learn more
about was um something called cell
reprogramming and you know
people maybe have heard of this
induced pluripotent stem cells where you
could take like a skin cell and turn it
back into a stem cell
and um shinya yamanaka won the nobel
prize for this work that was done in
2006
and um
you know it's kind of a crazy thing you
can turn one cell into another another
type of cell well
people recently have been
experimenting with um different types of
transcription factors that
would either not you don't want the cell
to go all the way back to being a stem
cell um you can end up getting like
cancerous cells and things like that but
you want it basically to the cell to
revert a little bit um earlier in its
you know it would call it the waddington
landscape but it's basically like um go
become act start to act like a bit of a
younger cell but not to to
de-differentiate and become more like a
stem cell and so i decided this might be
an interesting area to go fund
i think that that team has come together
there's like some really talented people
who've come together to help get that
off the ground and they're basically
building a
a platform that can test a lot of
different transcription factors on
different cell types and hopefully find
ways to rejuvenate different types of
cells and tissues to extend human health
span i mean the moonshot goal here you
know the get to mars
is um that there could be some therapy
here that in i don't know 10 or 20 years
that you take and from a whole body
point of view um it's sort of
rejuvenating tissue not just one type of
tissue like your immune system but
eventually your whole body maybe even
your brain so that
you know we don't have that issue where
people who are older have trouble
learning or they're more ossified in
their thinking
um
to me this is just i always think about
you know it's it's actually a little
inspired by elon right it's like what
are some of the biggest things in the
world like that are probably high
technology risk but if they did work
maybe they're they're kind of low chance
of working but if they did work would
have enormous impact i like the idea of
trying hard tech problems especially
for people like founders like me who've
made some money in software which i
think we're in kind of like a golden age
of software so there's like fortunes to
be made but if you if you do make some
money in that my hope is people will
like
do atoms not bits you know and try some
of the harder things like in biotech or
you know i guess he's doing cars and
rockets and stuff but
anyway it i think we should try hard
hard tech or you know physical science
problems as well and see if that can
advance
for team human
yeah so he's also doing bio with
neuralink
yeah and i feel like bio is tough yeah
because it's messy we don't understand
it as well we don't understand it the
risk is higher
in terms of uh not the risk is higher
but like you have to deal with
uh the actual sort of um to get to human
to get to stuff where it could be uh
therapies for actual human bodies
um
is is tricky because you have to prove
that it's safe it's effective all those
kinds of things with uh with fda i mean
it's just it's tricky it's very
difficult it's yeah it's a long it's a
long journey i mean
if i can give a quick um
plug so i yeah i'm on the board at new
limit we're hiring talented scientists
that are interested in the celebrity
programming space they don't necessarily
have to be
coming from like an aging background or
anything like that there's sort of a
small group of people doing even
something's a new thing this is a is new
limit relatively new yeah it's very new
there's a there's a small team today
just a handful of people and so we're
we're hiring more there
um if people are excited about that
space reach out and
um same thing for research hub there's a
small team there that's really awesome
that's
doing more like software engineering
design product
that kind of stuff
what advice would you give if you put on
your
old
wise sage hat
what advice would you give to young
people today high school
maybe undergrad and college
about life so like career
having a career they can be proud of
or maybe a life they can be proud of
so
people can do whatever they want to be
happy right so there's not one way to do
it
i do think that some people
a particular type of people out there a
lot of people actually they want to have
an impact on the world that's how they
get a sense of fulfillment right
so i mean you need to have like health
physical health you need to have good
relationships like
there's lots of things but most people
want to do something important they want
to have fulfilling work a way that they
can feel like they're contributing
i think a lot of people young people
today are are thinking like um you know
i should be an activist or something
like that
and there's people in the world who have
power and i and i don't a lot of people
who don't i don't have power and so the
way to change the world is to
you know um
speak truth to power or like criticize
power and
try to pressure them to change
to me i don't think that's the right way
to actually have an impact on the world
because
you know everybody has probably i think
people have more power than they realize
um and by the way it's easy to be a
critic
it's hard to actually change these
things and fix it and so um you'll get a
lot of accolades from friends and things
like that if you kind of go around
criticizing it you know it's easy to do
like everything is broken and could be
better
um including you know stuff i'm working
on i i find like
so frustrating it's the million things i
want to be better about like what we're
doing in coinbase
um
so be be the person in the arena you
know like that theodore roosevelt quote
i think he said it right like
go chew glass and stare into the abyss
like if if you really want to have an
impact either
join a company that has a mission that
is trying to fix the thing you're
passionate about or start start that
company if it doesn't exist or start a
charity if if it's not suitable to be a
company or whatever it is but
go try to be a part of this solution
don't
just you know criticize or be a part of
the problem my hope is that um
more people can
you know
realize that they they actually can have
a meaningful impact that way and i think
that
to me technology is actually one of the
most important ways to improve the world
like if if you look at
um climate change like
a lot of the best ideas like carbon
sequestration all these things it's a
technology thing right if you want to
try to fix education it's like look at
like khan academy and all the stuff
going online right if you want to if you
want to fix um you know whatever
transportation and like
um the financial system and global
freedom and like equality of all these
things like there's typically the way to
get
something changed in the world today is
with technology and so i do think people
it's very bizarre to me that there's
this kind of like anti-tech thing going
on
um look no nothing is perfect like if
you create something new and like
tens of millions of people use it or
billions people use it it's like
there's going to be some bad people who
use it too okay and there's you know
society is complicated but like i think
most of these things have been net
positive because most people in the
world are good is at least my view
so yes we can mitigate like the one
percent of bad people trying to you know
abuse something but 99 of people in the
world are good and the way you can
improve the world is with technology
joining companies starting companies
that are working on the right stuff so i
hope
i hope more young people do that and uh
just
if you're not sure what to do like just
get started with anything that's how you
learn and basically have the optimism
that you have the power to do the change
so
yeah um
it's easy to distract yourself by being
the critic
um that's almost like acknowledging to
yourself that that's all you can be
but
basically everybody has the power to be
the fixer
i like
chew glass and look into the abyss
um that's much more fun than it sounds
[Laughter]
uh what do you think is the meaning of
this whole thing why are we here
it's life
yeah what's the meaning of life what's
this existence we got
you're trying to increase the amount of
economic freedom on this planet earth
trying to alleviate some of the
suffering yeah but why
i don't really think there is any point
to life um
you know uh
somebody once told me um
you know if you go into these like kind
of really big existential questions
um it can get a little scary because
like you you stare off the cliff and
there's like there's nothing there you
know um
one this one person told me one time
they were like
you know brian you should you should
probably s uh snorkel don't scupa
i guess and i think they were trying to
say like
i i some of my friends have done this
right they'd they'll go to like you know
epic medita meditation retreats and like
all they'll kind of come back with all
this
existential dread of like what's the
meaning of all and like as far as i can
tell we are just some organic molecules
in the ocean started like dividing and
replicating and the selfish gene and all
this stuff like basically ended up here
and our only it's it's some kind of like
really naive algorithm that's just kind
of trying to get us to survive and
replicate and we have dna just like
every other animal and so we and we
happen to develop these like really cool
neocortexes and so now we're sort of
self-aware and we have all these big
questions
and maybe
maybe we'll create another you know as
computers get better we'll create the
simulation inside our thing and
um i think it's cool like we should
basically i just want to keep watching
the movie you know unfold that's part of
why i want to work on um like new limit
is really cool because it's help if
people can live longer whether that's
uploading their brain to the cloud or
um you know basically through we get
biology to work or the strong ai to work
or whatever one of those two hopefully
works out and then we get to we get to
keep watching the movie and see how it
all unfolds i think that's fun and so
i don't know if that's like an answer
but i guess i don't think there's any
real purpose so just try to have fun
well the cool thing is that uh we get to
write the movie as it as as we watch it
yeah
that's exactly right i mean that's like
the steve jobs quote and all that where
he's like everything around you was
invented by some somebody who just was
like that this is a crazy idea they
thought up so
once you realize you can kind of do
anything you want
um
then
that's what you start to go you start to
go try crazier stuff i mean what this is
another one of those areas where um not
to get too out there but like you know
when you're when i was i think you can
build your comfort zone around like
people being upset with you you can also
build your
your range of what you think is possible
right like
when i was a when i was in my 20s i was
like reading all these books about like
self-improvement and goal right how to
write down your goals and stuff and
my goals were like
someday i want to
make a hundred thousand dollars a year
or something like and that was
and you know um
and it seemed like a little outlandish
or what i wrote down these goals like i
want to own rental property or something
anyway
and i and then i slowly started to get
get some of these things done over a
couple of years and so i started to
think a little bigger
i remember one time i wrote down this
goal where i was like
what's the craziest thing i could think
of i was like what if i i want to write
i want to start a billion dollar tech
company
that's crazy and i had i had never
started like a million dollar tech
company or any any tech company really
so what business did i have writing that
goal down i remember i wrote that on a
piece of paper like
like probably every day for a year or
something almost right i don't know if
it was every day but like i wrote it
down a lot and
and so little things started to happen i
was like all right well maybe i should
move back to the bay area from buenos
aires maybe i should
try to apply to y combinator or whatever
like and i started thinking about these
ideas and so whatever gets you fired up
it doesn't have to be like some company
goal or startup thing it could be
anything right
um maybe you want to publish a book or
like do something creatively or whatever
anyway
you you know i think like within
seven years
uh no it's probably more like 10 years
of me writing that goal down
um coinbase had a valuation over a
billion dollars
so it
it was out of my realm of what was even
possible
and then
within 10 years you can you can
accomplish more in 10 years than you
think less than in a year than you think
so now i start now i'm like okay what's
the next goal what's the crate okay
maybe
i want to get a billion people accessing
the open financial system through
our products every day you know that
would be cool for for humanity and
that's a pretty crazy goal like it's
only eight billion people or something
right so one out of eight
um
or maybe i can radically like if i make
some like the right investments or
whatever i can like help
radically extend human health
human health span or whatever right
um
so
try crazier stuff i don't know even if
it doesn't work like hopefully you'll um
you'll
advance the state of affairs like
something interesting will happen and so
most people today they look at they look
at people trying this stuff and they're
like oh my god they're so they're a
genius or whatever and it's like or
they're an idiot like one of one of the
two
neither one are true it's just like um
anybody can start by thinking about what
they want and then like
go for it and then once you get that
like go for something a little bigger
and like you just have fun with it and
the universe is a way of smiling
and uh helping you out if you just write
it down and and you dream big yes
there's something about just
karma about
the energy you put into this world
other people will help you out doors
will open you'll notice that the doors
open
and you'll make you could actually have
a shot at making it happen it's a funny
world yeah i mean i don't i don't i
don't really subscribe to all like the
woo interpretations of this but my my
like very rational brain interpretation
of it is that if you just wake up every
day and write down like what you want to
get done and towards your longer goals
at your larger goals it's just it's just
on your mind that day so you start to
notice opportunities and you think about
it more so so brian thank you for
dreaming big um thank you for doing what
you're doing doing incredible
engineering at scale
uh trying to help out people from all
over the world and uh actually helping
me personally get more into crypto
just because it's so easy so um thank
you so much and
thank you so much for giving your
extremely valuable time today to this
awesome conversation thanks for your
awesome podcast i i love it i listen to
it often
thanks for listening to this
conversation with brian armstrong to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with some words
from benjamin franklin an investment in
knowledge
pays the best interest
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you